[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome welcome welcome to day three
draft represented by
rocket mortgage we are live on the br
app twitter
and youtube the fans are excited another
day where we are gonna see
some talented players achieve their
dreams i am excited to be here with all
of you guys
my name is taylor rooks and i am here
with the incomparable
connor rogers now connor you have been
doing this for two days
and it still ain't over how are you
still standing i'm getting well they had
to sit me down
today in the comfortable chairs right
they got us off the desk and said listen
you're gonna relax a little bit but
you know we're excited a lot of good
players left on the board i know a lot
of fans
have to be feeling really good right now
there's a lot of winners we're gonna
talk about
you know who really made out well on
days one and two it's been an exciting
two days taylor but i always say it
this is the day where you can go from
contender to super bowl champion because
you find those diamonds in the rough
yeah absolutely you find the diamonds in
the rough you always need to have
obviously that next man up mentality in
the nfl
and you get that next man up today but
this straps has really been
exciting i mean considering the
circumstances a lot of questions about a
lot of players
a lot of intrigue what have you found to
be a bit different about this year but
still
exciting well the quarterback
conversation's been crazy right and we
were all excited to see how these guys
would come off the board and the
the real conversation started at number
three with the niners you look at where
they gonna take mac jones
where are they gonna swing for the
fences on treyland so it's good to see
them betting on traits with trey lance
justin fields a little bit of a fall but
i think he falls into a great situation
for a team that felt strongly enough to
give up an extra first round pick to go
up and get him
in the chicago bears and mac jones and
the patriots i mean that's kind of a
match made in heaven when you look at
what they want to do
so that's been the big storyline for me
but a lot of teams have just gotten
great value
we saw a lot of strange picks that were
a lot of day three are projected
priority free agents yesterday
and the teams that sat behind those ones
came up and said hey i'll get this day
one player now you look at jeremiah wusu
cormoa that was one that stood out to me
we're gonna go through a lot of them but
there was just so many smart value picks
and there's so many players for a year
where
during the pandemic right you look at it
and everybody has all these questions
this is a small draft class and
you know guys opted out i don't have
those questions i think we see
just as much impact talent in the first
two days of this draft
as we usually do every year yeah and i
would say in some cases a bit
more talent than we we've seen you know
in some years really really
athletic guys and elite players that
we're seeing in this draft so tell me
your best
day one picks we'll start there yeah i
think when you look at it you have to
start with justin fields right you just
talk about
somebody that i thought was a top five
player a top three quarterback
and just someone that also was so so
polarizing in this draft class but the
athletic talent the arm strength the
accuracy
he's a player to me that i just think
can really change
everything about the bears they had a
tough era with mitsubishi everybody was
laughing when they got andy dalton of
course and then you look at him coming
in now and he's going to push the star
he's a player that
can attack vertically he's accurate at
all three levels
i like his leadership when he
transferred from georgia to ohio state
i think that team followed him and
that's why they won a lot of football
games so
i think a lot of people overthought
justin fields for whatever reason and
for the bears for a gm and a coach that
are trying to save their jobs
sure you paid a premium you went from 20
to 11 you gave up you know your first
round pick this year your first round
next year
it doesn't matter if you get a franchise
quarterback if justin fields is a top 10
quarterback in the nfl for the next 10
to 12 years
nobody cares about that extra first
round pick so i look at this situation
bears fans have to be thrilled to get
one of the most exciting players
in this trap that can elevate a team in
a tough division and then let's get back
to the guy at number 10 devonte smith i
mean the eagles
jumping the giants i think you could
understand where their thoughts were
doing business with the enemy in the
dallas cowboys the cowboys obviously
choosing which one of their enemies they
like
more lesser of the two evils that's
exactly what jerry's thinking over there
this guy's a rock star right i don't
care that he's 166 pounds he plays like
he's 210 contested catches in the sec
speed down the field
tracking the football really good before
and after the catch smart routes
i mean you heard reggie wayne say it on
day one he thought he was the best
player in this draft and you could make
that argument with the kind of heisman
season he had
the season before that i told everybody
if he declared after 2019
he was in the first round for me he went
back to school and said watch i got a
lot more left on the table i'm going to
win a heisman trophy and go in the top
ten
screw the end of your first round
projection so devonta smith is great
great for the eagles and i think for
jalen hurts it's just a situation where
he has to feel like wow they believe in
me they're giving me talent as we got
these tweets rolling in
yeah look at them they rang the bell at
the 76ers game so
it's always good when you can see two
friends reunite that chemistry is
instantly there and you will see it on
the football field but
right now we're seeing another
basketball court yeah yeah yeah but
guess what when they get to that
football field it's going to be just as
exciting
listen you look at the situation there
this is an eagles team that they need a
number one target and and we'll see what
jalen reagar has they're not going to
write him off
but now puts less pressure on him
devonte is going to come in he's the
number one target 10 to 12 targets a
game
the guy the go-to guy he owns that his
personality is i'm the dude on the field
throw me the football jalen hurts knows
a little bit about that yeah they're in
good shape you got to feel
really really good if you're a birds fan
they also got landon dickerson on day
two so they've made out really well yeah
absolutely and i agree he is instantly
wide receiver one he is going to get a
lot of opportunities to really shine
with the eagles okay let's move on to
your favorite day two picks
tell me what you like yeah so five more
five from day one five from day two and
these are all second rounders right here
tron merrick should not have fallen that
far the raiders have needed a cover
safety
a match-up player like this for a long
time i like that but aziz ogilari and i
know you're a fan taylor
he has no business falling to 50. this
is crazy and i know the medical red flag
from the combine
it never looked like it slowed him down
on the football field to tell you that
right now
a young player a two-time captain he was
a captain as a redshirt freshman
that's one of the most ridiculous things
i've ever heard in sec football or any
level of college football
azizo jillari for the giants he's just
what the doctor ordered they needed an
edge pass rusher in the worst kind of
way
they obviously felt like they had some
other needs to go to earlier
and they still get a round one player a
guy with great hands good get off the
snap
i mean he's really what i look for in
edge rushers can you get off the ball
and get up field and collapse the pocket
can you turn your ankle like that
and close to crush the quarterback
that's what he does hand in the dirt
standing up
they play a lot of different uh you know
fronts in that giants defense with
patrick graham the defensive coordinator
where
they're gonna look at him and use him in
different ways he's good off the ball
too against the run he could take on
pulling guards
like i said violent hands to come
downhill i'm a big azizo jillari fan and
good job for the giants that that's a
that's going to be a slam dunk for me
and speaking of slam dunks
what we have jeremiah wu so cormo you
heard me talk about him earlier but
let's get to terrace marshall
he was another round one player that
fell and it's the same situation
talking about the medical red flag from
indy i don't care it did not slow him
down on the field even when he was
behind justin jefferson and jamar chase
he caught double-digit touchdowns
terrace marshall's going to an offense
in carolina where everybody wants to see
what sam darnold can do
but the question marks they don't have
is that wide receiver with dj more
robbie anderson we know christian
mccaffrey can catch the ball well
you're telling me this guy's going to be
the number four target he's going to
thrive
he's going to catch a lot of touchdowns
if they get him on the field red zone
monster
really reminded me of denzel mims can
win vertically big catch radius
some concentration drops but a younger
guy i think he can clean those up
and neck offensive coordinator joe brady
he had terrace marshall catch 13
touchdowns for him on a national title
team you know he was banging the table
for him in the draft room
and then close it out with creed
humphrey to kansas city creed humphrey
man he's just one of the high floor
players of this draft a three-year
starter at center
played on a lot of good offensive lines
at oklahoma didn't allow a sack in
college former wrestler
those big tough hands patrick mahomes
last week we saw patrick mahomes he was
running around like a maniac for his
life in the super bowl
with joe tooney orlando brown
humphrey they said never again
now tell me speaking of patrick holmes
tell me what you thought of the
quarterbacks
um so far what quarterbacks that were
available in the first two days yeah i
think when you look at it
it's been you know crazy to watch these
guys come off the board but not
not unexpected they all have just
incredible incredible traits to be top
five pastors
trevor lawrence zach wilson we talked
about fields
you know mack jones will be interesting
trey lance is in a good situation
you like to see kellan mon davis davis
mills interesting and with the texans
but kyle trask
they're more developmental guys so i
think when you look at it
this was an exciting quarterback class a
lot of them have big expectations early
right i mean trevor lawrence gonna be a
week one starter zach wilson week one
starter trey lance
everybody's talking about how he didn't
play last year only had over a little
over 300 passing attempts coming out of
the fcs
dominated as a 19 year old in that
league
he's got to play he needs reps taylor
you can't sit him it's not sitting
behind jimmy g
get him on the field justin fields he's
too good when they get into training
camp they're going to have him and andy
dalton thrown side by
side the coaches are going to be
laughing in the meeting room oh you mean
uh andy dalton qb1
yeah qb1 short-lived
big josh rosen he's our buy uh he's our
guy oh totally
so mac jones i think cam newton will
hold him off i don't think matt jones is
a starter out of day one a lot of people
feel he's a pro ready player
cam's not going to let that go too
easily and i i'm a little higher on cam
cam in year two of that offense with
actually signing skill talent this year
and rebuilding the offensive line like i
said
the day two quarterbacks i went
yesterday uh we heard rg3 do a great job
breaking them down
they're gonna sit and wait their turn a
little bit but kelanman is the guy that
intrigues me in minnesota i like the
talent and i like the improvement in
2020.
now you've already talked about the
importance of day three this is where
you know the champions are built getting
that depth
getting those guys that you need to just
do the work tell me
your favorite guys that are still
available today yeah trey smith the
guard from tennessee i mean former
powerhouse recruit came in
played some tackle for them played some
played some guard at a really high level
before suffering a blood clot issue
and that kept him off the field for a
while and i would imagine there's some
medical concerns there or
or just question marks and this is why
he's still on the board but trey smith
bounced back
really well from that blood clot
situation played at a high level
he's a bully he's a tough guy in the
middle of the field i'm excited to see
where he goes in a
gapping gap blocking scheme drive
blocking you know really really utilizes
power jabril cox
coverage linebacker has no business
being on the board with some of the
names that got called yesterday
a north dakota state transfer to lsu i
thought he was the best cover linebacker
maybe in the entire draft right now
i'm sure you'll hear his name called
real early i know the new york jets
picked second today
they could use a cover linebacker like
that tylan wallace the deep threat one
of the most productive
receivers in college football over the
last three years kenny gainwell and opt
out from memphis great pass catching
back
jamar johnson some of the best range in
this class at the safety position one
year starter great ball skills
deonte brown same thing as trey smith
powerhouse guard
you know pretty good feat for a big guy
uh 350 pounds
he's huge quincy rochet great get off
the snap he's got a little juices
situational pass rusher
brevin jordan his teammate down there at
the u pass catching tight end reminds me
of irv smith i went to the vikings a
couple years ago
patrick johnson from tulane one of my
favorite sleepers in this entire draft
the whole package has an edge rusher a
stand-up edge rusher so you look at it
there and then hamsa nazardeen
this is these are all starters right
here not maybe not day one but they're
all future starters for me in the nfl
what do you think is going kind of
through those guys mind right now as
they're sitting and waiting jaguar
select right now getting a
dt which is a need that they did need to
address tell me about this guy yeah
toufele
you know an interesting player that
opted out this year and those opt outs
are being evaluated in different ways
and somebody that is an attacking three
tech right that interior defensive line
uh get up field shoot the gap so you
heard about levi owens enrique yesterday
it's kind of the light version of him
right somebody that can create havoc
rush the passer
you know maybe not the most stout guy
right now maybe not the greatest athlete
but a pretty good one
honestly a compact pass rusher i saw
power
i had him right in the top of the fourth
round where are we right now taylor top
of the fourth round perfect
perfect fit here this is nice for them
they needed help on the interior
defensive line and i like jacksonville's
strategy here i always say with interior
defensive line
you can wait till day three if you want
the quinn williams kind of players
fletcher cox
aaron donald you got to take them early
they're explosive but can you get
starters at the top of day three on the
interior defensive line you absolutely
can and we didn't get to see two fella
this year
but the last time we did i thought he
was a really nice player i do think he's
a nice rotational piece for them they're
trying to figure out what they have and
tave and brian this is really nice
insurance right here
yeah it's always interesting you know we
say okay they need a defensive tackle
but a team like the jaguars coming up
that season
they kind of needed a little bit of
everything yeah so what they're doing
right now is really trying to fill in
those gaps i think that that
is you know a really good pick for them
let's take a look at some some tweets
you know as twitter is still buzzing
about the nfl drafts let's see my
favorite pick so far is without a doubt
aziz which by the way i know you could
not believe
aziz was even still available it's
pretty insane when you have a top 20
player
top you know top edge pass rusher
it's just someone that really really
stands out to me yeah absolutely now you
know this is
all about winning a super bowl we saw a
bunch of off-season moves of teams
trying to do just that we
obviously have a bit of a quarterback
carousel but tell me some players
that you think went to new teams and
kind of made them instant contenders
yeah i think when you look at arizona
just look at the draft weekend so far
right
when you start with arizona getting
rondell moore that's the electric
playmaker i know people are talking
about hey you got hopkins we know how
good d-hop is we don't have to waste
time on that he just lights out
aj green you know we'll see what the end
of the career brings it's going to be
interesting there
you get a totally different player in
rondell moore the electric factory
that's what me and reggie were saying
yesterday he's just somebody to get the
ball in his hands
make plays we're going to learn a lot
about arizona right cliff kingsbury all
the hype remember the draft pick from a
couple of years ago chilling in the
living room
i mean he's the freshest coach in the
nfl but it's got to translate to results
that's what matters right now so
you look at it kyler murray he's been
good i would like to see him go be great
and i think now he has the offense
around him to go be great so arizona
they needed to make some moves on
defense well they did jj watt at the
tail end of his career still plays at a
high level when he's on the field they
need to help a corner this is a team
that lives in nickel by the way
over 90 percent of their snaps are
that's their base defense three corners
on the field what do you do you get
malcolm butler i'd still like to see
them draft a couple of corners as well
and want kyler to be great short up that
offensive line rodney hudson maybe the
most reliable center in the last
five years of the nfl so arizona i'm not
going to say
they've taken that contender jump but
they put all the pieces there to do it
it's put up or shut up i mean let's be
real you might be in the hardest
division in all the football we know
what seattle we know what the rams can
do of course
it's going to be really fascinating to
see how they compete in that division
right now
now you mentioned the rims what can the
rams do some big moves out in la as well
yeah i mean matt stafford in town you
know not too shabby
not too shabby and i know they're really
excited about that there with stafford
and he's somebody that can take the
offense to the next level brings a
little more than jared goff right can
play in that a structure
they have desean jackson you got your
speed guy they have a lot of talent at
wide receiver
so when you look at this football team
they get leonard floyd back on a pretty
hefty contract good for leonard floyd to
cash out there
playing next to aaron donald he's really
found his place in the nfl now after a
slow start
the rams are interesting i mean they've
had some movement from their staff
getting hired away
but they got a big piece at quarterback
sean mcveigh knows they can get this
offense scoring over 30 points a game
cam akers you know really going to take
over at running back i thought that's a
move they should have made earlier last
year
i think cam makers is ready to be the
star in that backfield give them a
little more explosiveness so the rams
they are a team that should take that
next step did not like their draft let
me just be honest with that they did
nothing for me yesterday that malibu
house is getting too crazy they're not
paying attention
but the free agency moves off season
moves they did a good job yeah
absolutely okay so going over to the
east coast you know bill belichick went
and he
got mack what were your thoughts on that
pick yeah
listen mack jones it's a good situation
for him you don't got to start right
away a lot of people felt he was a pro
ready quarterback
i would like to see him get some second
team reps and slowly ease in that's
great for any rookie quarterback people
forget matt jones is a one-year starter
nobody likes to talk about that mac
jones is a one-year starter
really nice additions i mean they went
out and bought an offense taylor they
brought the bag and said we'll buy every
top free agent on offense hunter henry
johnny smith
great tight end tandem they want to get
back to those two tight end sets that
made that new england offense real
famous a long time ago
nelson aguilar quietly has turned to his
career around since philadelphia he was
great for the raiders last year
we know what trent brown can do when he
puts on a patriots uniform that's where
he needs to be
matthew don really good pass rusher over
the years for baltimore coming over
there they give him big money to get
after the quarterback
nice reliable player for that defense
new england's had a pretty nice draft as
well they got christian barmore up front
they feel like they can coach him up to
be a special player on the inside
but it's going to be about mac jones
that's what it's about it's going to be
about mack jones so
i want to see cam ball out with these
new weapons first and when it's max time
then it'll be max time
now england's got they got to keep busy
miami and the bills
looking real good the jets coming out of
the basement
new quarterback making some nice picks
afc east on the rise now england's got
to
you know keep where they've been yeah
now as we kind of stay on this line of
quarterbacks obviously carson wins now
in
indianapolis what about the pieces that
will now be surrounding him
yeah and he needs pieces we know that
things fell apart real bad in philly and
i'm not going to put it all on carson
once but i will put some of it on them
because obviously when they felt strong
enough to ship him out and move to jalen
hurts
it says a lot about you you gotta go
prove them wrong now so
some big moves here right you get carson
wentz we know
his you know familiarity with this
coaching staff that's the most important
thing for him you got some questions on
your offensive line
and maybe that's something that they
addressed today with these day three
players
i like picking quitty pay i think he's a
difference maker up front especially
against the run like his athleticism
like his ceiling
as a pass rusher in this defense so with
the colts they're well coached team
chris ballard and ed dodds maybe the
best front office duo gm and assistant
gm
in the entire nfl they draft as well as
anyone and accumulate picks
the colts are in the driver's seat if
they can get carson wentz back to form
you know now as we talk about kind of
this quarterback carousel i want to
stick with carson once because that
situation is
really interesting to me because you
know some philly fans kind of argued
that the situation maybe wasn't right
for him
what about the situation in indianapolis
maybe makes it better
well this is a team that knows how to
run the football they're a power
run team with quentin nelson now no more
anthony castanzo you're gonna have to
address that at some point
but we know what the rest of this
offensive line can do i mean let's be
real they're gonna run the football and
protect their quarterback
they got some pass catchers out there
now and they got a coach that
loves this quarterback that is excited
to work with him the feeling is mutual
i think the wheels fell off the bus
there with wence and doug peterson and
the front office it was a uh
a three-way you know stick them up kind
of stare at each other or stare down so
it's good that they all get fresh starts
i'm i'm not a big believer in wence
overall as the superstar mvp player that
he once was
but can he be serviceable in
indianapolis absolutely so i think
that's the most important thing for them
they could be good enough on the
defensive side of the ball they don't
need him to be a superstar
now sam darnold of course now in
carolina panthers picked up his fifth
year option making it clear that to them
qb what do you think makes them so
confident well the fact that they got
more talent around him than sam has ever
seen in his life
i mean and it starts off the field with
joe brady one of the best young play
callers in the nfl
if he fixes sam darnold and gets him
right joe brady's not going to be there
when that fifth year option kicks in
i mean that's what it comes down to
right now joe brady will be a head coach
in the nfl
this time next year when we're sitting
here on the draft so you got dj moore
you got robbie anderson who'll be afraid
at the end of the year you got teres
marshall you've got three wide receivers
that
have all held number one roles at some
point in their lives christian mccaffrey
arguably a top 2-3 running back in the
league
the offensive line is really really
coming together they made a nice pick
with brady christensen you got taylor
moton franchise tag player
this offense will be much more dedicated
and tailored to what sam darnold is good
at rolling out cutting the field in half
throwing on the run you got to cut down
those turnovers sam you can't take your
team out of games you got all the
weapons to do you got all the coaching
staff in the world there
i'm excited to watch the panthers
because this can this can explode
this offense but the guy in the driver's
seat sitting behind the wheel
he needs to get right now speaking of
exploding
there's you know little-known qb named
aaron rodgers who just kind of blew
up this entire weekend for everybody
looks like we have an
a-rod update saying that he thinks
there's a less than a
5 chance that aaron rodgers placed a
single down
as a packer in 2021 that coming from rob
demofsky
wow this seemingly uh came out of
nowhere
from what you have heard do you believe
it's fairly unlikely that we see
aaron rodgers in that green bay uniform
yeah he's dug in i don't see any way
that he just says hey you know what it's
fine now so i think when you look at it
for aaron rodgers i don't think green
bay is going to pick up the phone
anytime soon
i mean we saw this play out with deshaun
watson in houston teams don't russell
wilson
as well he seems to want to trade
franchise superstar quarterbacks
i think for rogers he's dug in don't
think he'll return to green bay i think
for green bay they're not going to be in
a hurry on this they'll roll with jordan
love
yeah do you think it really is this was
because jordan love
jordan love really began this rift you
know what i think it's because
of accumulation of things obviously
taking them off the field
in the postseason i think they're i
don't know if he's ever fully meshed
with the coaching stat maybe the front
office more than the coaching staff
but absolutely taylor you drafted his
replacement
you drafted the man's replacement and
then he won an mvp
so you told him hey we think you're done
after this year and he said
no i'm actually maybe the best player in
the nfl quite the response that's pretty
i think we can all aspire to do that you
slighted me but then i'm gonna go and be
the best so
good on you aaron rodgers definitely
gonna be really interesting uh to
continue to watch both today and
probably throughout the rest of the off
season now remember
fans out there share your video
breakdowns
of your team's draft in the nfl draft
community on the br
app and we might send you you know some
vr gridiron merch look at that the
classic black and white
get some merch from one of your favorite
players in the draft
all right super excited about this guest
my friend and jacksonville jaguars
co-owner tony khan
joins the show right now first tony
congrats on what seems to be a very
successful draft so far which begins
with acquiring trevor lawrence with the
first overall pick
it obviously reached a point where
everybody knew trevor was going to come
to jacksonville
but for you what exact moment did you
know
trevor was your guy uh well
you know having paid a lot of attention
to college football over the last few
years there's been nobody
that's made the impact trevor lawrence
has his team's always been
competing in the postseason he hasn't
lost a regular season game since high
school
and uh he's put up some of the most
impressive statistics
i've seen and i think we had consensus
here throughout scouting and coaching
so i would say i knew for sure trevor
was going to be here
once we hired urban meyer because urban
felt the same way very strongly about
trevor lawrence
so we had great consensus across
everybody from scouting coaching
and analytics yeah seemed like probably
one of the
the easier decisions that you will make
in life right
definitely i mean it felt like a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and
you know you never know until we start
playing the games but to me
uh i remember where i was as a kid when
peyton manning got drafted
and it was an iconic player it was
somebody
who i'd really respected as a college
football player and
you know they've had different careers
or different people but definitely to me
uh it feels like a landmark day in the
nfl and it's really cool
to for us to be a part of it yes
absolutely i mean obviously the the
choice was obvious but
is the pressure heavier or lighter when
you have the first overall pick
uh in some ways i think it's both i
think there's a lot of pressure on the
pick i mean it's the highest leverage
pick it's the most important pick
and it's probably the most pressure
there is on any pick in the draft to
succeed both the player and on the team
so there is that
but on the other hand uh i think it's
easier in some ways
because it's the first time i've ever
gone into the draft with a hundred
percent certainty
of who we're picking because like every
year people ask you
who are you drafting and you know i tell
people the same thing every year it
depends on who the people before us are
drafting
so this is uh my 10th draft in the nfl
and it's the first time i've been able
to say
that i knew we were gonna all right tony
so walk me through that decision-making
process
choosing travis atn at number 25 you
know first quarterback running back duo
to be drafted in the first round
take me through that yeah well you know
it was
tons of scouting meetings great
communication between urban meyer and
the coaching staff
our new offensive coordinator daryl
beville our scouting team led by trent
our gm
and our analytics group which is led by
myself and
karim kasam who just joined us this year
he had done five years with the
pittsburgh steelers
and he had just been at the minnesota
twins
he's got a phd in psychology from
harvard and
uh they had a degree in computer
engineering and so
uh all of us get together and meet on a
regular basis and had
communicated a lot of travis etienne was
a name that had come up a ton
i think in terms of trevor lawrence we
we got the work done and we all felt
very comfortable
months ago and that gave us a lot of
time to prepare and think about what
we've done
you know this weekend and so i really
think
that with travis settiend coming into
the team we've had
a great great opportunity to add speed
to the run game obviously but also to
the pass game travis etienne's been one
of the top running backs and he's made
great contributions on the ground at
clemson
but he's also been the most productive
running back in the pass game
in america which rover lawrence is his
quarterback
and over the last two seasons we've seen
etienne rack up 1021 receiving yards
and no other receiver in the ncaa's had
even 800.
so he's definitely been contributor in
the past game and to us
that's a huge part of you know making
trevor lawrence successful here
and getting the ball out making him
comfortable
so we think this is going to help us
both in the wrong game and in the past
game
and also running the ball is going to be
important to this team too
and so etienne and james robinson carlos
hyde
we have one of the deepest running back
rooms in the nfl
uh you know we picked up what we think
is a generational quarterback prospect
who we really believe in
and we've got a great receiver group so
now it's you know
really a lot of speed on offense and
that's really important to us
yeah absolutely and it's hard to say no
to to a reunion
so i'm looking forward to seeing both of
those guys offensively on your team now
you're a big analytics guy as you
mentioned so what are the numbers
showing you about where and how this
team can improve
this upcoming season uh that's great
question i think we need to improve
in the past game obviously the win
column is the most important
area in which we need to improve and so
when you look back at
this past season you know turnovers not
turning the ball over is going to be
very important to us
we had a great running back james
robinson last year who came in as an
undrafted rookie
which is kind of my specialty uh
undrafted players and
i work on you know trying to find the
best guys who slip through the draft
every year and james robinson was one of
those players and he came in
and she achieved at unprecedented level
uh for an undrafted running back really
for any rookie running back
and so uh you know i think he's been a
huge contributor for us
dj shark two seasons ago was a huge part
of our offense this past year
you know injuries and some things slowed
him down he's come in this year
under coach urban meyer and made huge
huge strides in the weight room and we
really believe dj chart can be a great
contributor
we've added free agent receivers to make
huge help in the past game marvin jones
is going to come in
he's been a great nfl player he's been a
great receiver going back to cal
and we think marvin jones can help us a
lot philip dorsett's going to add a ton
of speed for our team
on offense which again is a theme adding
speed to the to the offense
into the pass game and so i think that
you know for us uh these are areas on
offense where we plan to make strides
defensively we need to get better in
coverage i mean
that's a huge huge importance for us
you know a few years ago when we went to
the afc championship game
we were the top defense in the nfl in
many categories and we were
in the top two or three in most
statistical categories on defense
particularly in the past game we made
great strides in the run game that year
at the trade deadline when we added
marcel darius
and really became a good team stopping
the run too
but against the pass we were elite in
2017 and i think we need to be elite
in the past game and we need to hold up
in the run game too defensively
and so i believe that we got a great
opportunity now
uh with the players we drafted uh to do
that
and so uh you know we've beefed up the
secondary big time
in the past couple days to help in the
past game
no absolutely well you know tony uh can
we get a tim tebow update
i cannot uh you know tim has definitely
come in and worked out
so uh beyond that i can't say too much
but tim has come in and worked out as a
tight end
uh that's not you know uh
not the position that we've seen him
play sometimes but his position that uh
he's been practicing at with us
so uh that'll be interesting to see how
that contributes to us on offense too
but obviously urban knows tim really
well
and tim's got a great history of winning
and
urban really believes he can help us and
i think it makes a lot of sense and it's
a position where we need to get better
yeah
few things more exciting than tim tebow
doing something else so that
that would be really fun to watch if it
comes to fruition
thank you so much for joining us tony
you know i have to end with an ill
ini it's i always appreciate that and i
i wish uh
our basketball season had ended a little
differently taylor but
i have a feeling that next year could be
a good year for the illini basketball
and hopefully for the illini football
too
yes we'll be back and we'll be at some
games it'll be fun wins all around
let's go and they respect cams and
everything thank you taylor yes
bye
i used to have a landlord who thought he
could fix everything here we go again
he could not
when you need to throw in the towel on
renting rocket cam
you got any tape
all right let's check back in on the
giants connor you know jay glazer giants
are having a terrific draft both of
their selections
and with picking up extra picks
seriously shout out to gettleman i feel
like he just put on the
master class in this year's draft i
don't even know who this version of dave
gettleman is
i've been trading back what's happening
i've been running my joke into the
ground that he got a smartphone like
it's
people haven't seen this from him
honestly when you look at it they
acquired more picks
they got really good value on players
even you know someone like aaron
robinson that i think can be a starter
for them later on
we love aziz you know tony's gonna have
a role
everybody's loving what the giants are
doing and rightly so this is
and listen taylor this goes you're gonna
hear me say this too much but you hear
it with sam darnold
you're here with a lot of these
quarterbacks daniel jones has to get it
done
this is loaded this offense they have
like five legitimate pass catchers
a superstar running back that's going to
be healthy now
he's got it all and i think daniel jones
has a chance
to succeed with these guys but once
again you just got to take care of the
football
it's very similar to sam in carolina
right it's all there but the guy in the
driver's seat has to make it go
yeah and see that's what my question is
going to be you know you have this
revamped offense
a bunch of elite guys and we know that
daniel has to get it done
but do you think that he will what's
going to be that thing that propels him
from the have to to okay i did i think
just the decision making
and it's you know the fumbles are one
thing you got to keep the guy clean in
the pocket he does have a fumbling
problem but you also need to protect him
and the tackle should grow
you look at the tackles andrew thomas
and matt pert that they took last year
they should get better
the interior still has some questions i
think they're going to look to solve
that today
but get the ball out quickly and that's
on jason garrett build an offense that
is less on your quarterback scheme open
your first read guy you got evan ingram
in the middle of the field
we know how much money to give kenny
gallaudet cadarius tony is going to be
open a lot for manufactured touches and
screens
saquon's a good pass catching running
back these are guys that
the offense doesn't have to be slow
moving it can be quick and daniel jones
is an athletic guy so maybe get him on
the move a little bit more
i know i said all the time young
quarterbacks but cut the field in half
give them different leveled reads
i think that he has a chance but when
you turn the ball over it takes your
team out of games and we just haven't
seen him
stop really stop himself from doing that
all right now speaking of the giants
revamped
offense now joining us is former ole
miss titan
and now new york giant evan ingram evan
always
amazing to see you you're in georgia
right now what's up where are you for
the off season
yeah um i'm i'm in off season i'm in
georgia
i'm training back at home i'm right now
i'm actually in oxford
i'm back at ole miss uh for my boys
having some fun
yeah a little bit a little bit all right
now eventful couple days for your squad
of course some picks
some trades it's been exciting tell me
your immediate reaction when you see the
giants are trading back
going from the 11th pick to the 20th
um i mean it's i'm probably the same as
everybody else
they don't tell us anything so when i
find out that stuff
um it's the same time as you do so um
but yeah it was it was surprising um you
know
the giants haven't don't ever really
trade back so that was kind of
different but um yeah i think we made a
great pick i'm in the first round all of
our pick has been pretty good
um and i think we're adding a lot of
talent to our team and
i'm just just ready to get these guys in
and get to work
yeah did you ever envision the eagles
and the cowboys
teaming up just to jump y'all and get a
pick in
yeah that was that was wild um that was
well i did i did peep that but
um yeah we got a crazy division so um it
doesn't surprise me
big shout out to dave gettleman though i
salute the moves
hauled in some talent still maximizing
future picks
giants still somehow someway acquired
talented georgia linebacker aziz ogilari
what will he bring to your defense
um i think he's just another dynamic
player that's going to come off the edge
and
and be um can probably play different
spots
i know our defense moves guys around a
lot um and
and i think he can come in and with the
right mindset and and the hard work um i
think he can really help us
take me into the giants group chat
specifically like the giants offensive
group chat
so cadarius tony's announced okay tell
me
who sends the first text what does it
say
uh we we we do have a group chat we
didn't really talk that much
throughout the draft about about the
pick but i think uh once once
cadarius gets in there i'm in our
offensive group chat i think he can
bring his uh his personality and and
kind of join in the family and um and be
a part of the group so
um definitely don't really haven't
really talked about it but uh we're
gonna we're gonna get them in there as
soon as possible though
so many weapons now on offense you
saquon sterling shepard darius leigh and
now kenny gallaudet and cadarius
in what ways will we see this team
improve offensively
next season um i think i think
this is going to show um all our work
that we're putting in um is just going
to have to
have to show i think we have a lot of
talent i mean all those names you just
listed off
um are really dynamic players and and
great guys and great locker room guys as
well so
uh we're building a team we're building
a culture um and now we just gotta put
the work in and go out there and perform
yeah i mean how exciting is that for you
just to hear that slew of names
that daniel jones now has at his
disposal
i think i mean it definitely excites me
you know
just having talent around offense as
defensive pines and
i'm going to have to play different ways
things are going to open up and
i think like i said with all our work
that we're going to put in
and the job that our coaches are doing
and plays are drawing up and
for us to go execute i'm excited and i
think we have a chance to be a dynamic
team
all right the giants also just made a
pick drafted defensive end
ellerson smith so this defense
is just getting more stacked and stacked
and stacked
what do you think giants fans will see
from the d next season
um what they saw last year i mean just a
gritty group
guys are flying around dynamic players
that can play anywhere
from the d-lines linebackers to the
secondary
guys can move around and be athletic and
and be dynamic
our defense plays with chip on the
shoulder they come hungry and
i think imagine these young guys
as the draft goes on and even through
free agency
i think our defense is going to have a
chance to be really dynamic and uh
dangerous
and going to go hunting for us all right
evan now obviously you are a giant but
you and i
we're both in georgia folks and you know
that i
love the falcons so happy that we've got
kyle pitts
so give me your tight end tight end
evaluation of
kyle uh i think yeah kyle is
probably the biggest um for sure pick um
in this draft
without a doubt uh he literally can do
everything um
just i mean he's built like megatron um
at tight end
it's really scary um and he's gritty i'm
in the running game too so you can get
in there and block but
i don't think they're going to be asking
the block that much with how talented he
is so
um yeah i think the falcons got the best
skill player in the draft
and i just always always wish him the
best and love to see
my fellow tight ends uh ball out yeah
i'm feeling good about the falcons but
you know i say that every single year
um elijah moore every single year i'm
like i'm going to super bowl and then
i'm like okay please ignore what i just
said evan
elijah moore was an absolute stud for
your ole miss rebels last season how
surprised were you to see him you know
drop to the second round
um you know it was surprising i had
elijah's obviously probably a little
biased but
he was my favorite receiver in the draft
just just a great player
can play any words i'm complaining the
backfield being the slot to play outside
real
real chris rock runner um and obviously
he went to ole miss
so you know he's gonna ball so but
definitely i was surprised to see him
slip out the first
round but i'm glad to have him down the
street in new york
i think he's going to be great for them
and help them get going i'm offensive
side of the ball
yes absolutely well evan thank you so
much for your time have an
amazing season this offense is going to
be a delight to watch
and i cannot wait have a great day
definitely thank y'all
bye evan
all right how about that i'm excited
thinking about the giant's offense just
after talking to him
i mean just loaded and he even you know
being the nice guy he is snuck in a
little jets love with the elijah moore
pick so his favorite receiver in the
draft and those ole miss guys have each
other's back so yeah that's
i mean if you're a giants fan you got to
be
so excited right now so excited it's
almost like okay how can this go wrong
yeah
well as a new york sportsman uh yeah i
could tell you a lot of ways
there are a couple ways that could go
wrong but no it's definitely going to be
exciting we want to take a quick moment
to thank rocket mortgage for sponsoring
our entire draft coverage
for more than 35 years rocket mortgage
has been simplifying
the home loan process by designing it
around you
real-time loan options real-time closing
costs real-time tax estimates
if it's 7 pm on a sunday guess what
rocket mortgage has got you covered
so when you need a mortgage to fit your
family rocket can
all right so this year i think what
we're seeing
a lot with these players there are some
questions around them
but a lot of hype as well oh yeah what
is kind of the backhandedness to that i
think if you have a lot of hype around
you
but not a lot that has shown of it you
really feel like you have to live up to
this expectation
yeah i think people are you know always
afraid of landing spots right because
it's tough to succeed if you're in a
place that does not fit very well and
let's talk about some of these recent
picks i'll start we already did two fele
michael carter to the jets they don't
have a running back taylor so this is
this is kind of the guy right away and
he was the the 1b
he was the lightning to javonte williams
thunder at unc
michael carter is going to be a really
really exciting player in that wide zone
running scheme and
man did the jets need one you know you
look at james hudson developmental
tackle for the browns
i love cam sample for the bengals just a
tough guy on the
defensive end hand in the dirt kind of
player understands leverage knows how to
get under the pads and control the point
of the attack
love his ability as a power rusher and
more importantly as a run stopper
and then you look at amman ross st brown
for the lions get jared goff some help a
guy that goes up and wins the football
so
a lot of nice value picks here but also
a lot of nice players left on the board
right now so you're looking at it still
going i know we've been waiting
for jabril cox it sounds like the dallas
cowboys are taking him off the board one
of the best cover linebackers in the
entire draft
speaking of those giants they got
ellerson smith a developmental pass
rusher that really really caught my eye
so i think that's a nice pick i'm
curious how they address the interior of
this offensive line
trey smith and deontay brown are still
sitting on the board maybe they find a
way to get one of those guys but
when you look at this tylan wallace and
kenny gainwell we're going to talk to
the fantasy footballers today
those are players that should make an
impact in fantasy football and in real
football just as past catching players
and
with dynamic speed as well especially
for tylan wallace kenny gainwell
more shifty so a lot of talent left on
the board talked about cam sample from
tulane how about his teammate patrick
johnson
that plays across from him the team
captain those guys were exciting to
watch play together i'm excited to see
where patrick johnson ends up
what exactly are fans going to get from
jabril cox i know that's somebody you
have
you've been fairly high on yeah i mean
just great in coverage
great coverage and not a lot of
linebackers can move like that right
those are the big guys in the middle of
the field but you need in this league
players that can run with tight ends run
with running backs
move out to the slot especially with a
lot of motion in today's nfl so you look
at jabril cox
you already took micah parsons you have
jalen smith you know leighton van dyrash
those are going to be your big thumpers
in the middle that make sure nobody runs
all over you
they sign count on you they're crowded
right now they signed keanu neil from
your falcons
it's so the crowded group in the middle
of the field but gibral cox will give
you something on special teams as well
while also being a sub package player uh
in those nickel and dime looks
two and one linebacker looks on the
field i also i don't want to sound too
crazy or get too ahead of myself
but i think the cowboys are going to
beat dangerous i mean micah parsons
they need a defense yeah they need and
they got it i mean
he if you ask me was probably the most
athletic player in the draft
he was my top defensive player and a lot
of people slept on him a little bit i
don't know if it's because he didn't
play last year or what the deal was
i thought he was the most dynamic
defensive player in the entire draft but
and then you put jabril cox next to him
once again it's these complimentary duos
right you look at your braille he's
gonna be your cover guy
i think parsons can get there but you
want parsons playing downhill you want
him blitzing you want him stopping the
run you want him
in the middle of your defense calling
everything so for the cowboys
the real you know dynamic question here
is what are they going to get from
kelvin joseph the corner they took
yesterday
that's a boomer bus pick uh mr bossman
fat is what they call him
that's the boomer bus pick for the
cowboys but it's good to see them taking
swings on defense to get that going in
the right direction but if you had to
pick for him what are we seeing boom or
bust
and your estimation putting you on the
spot it was early
i i had him you know right at right
around i think player 100 they took him
in the second round
little early for my liking uh there was
better players on the board
that coaching staff you know keebs said
it yesterday they'll have somebody to
hold his hand
is what a cube said that gave me a
little bit more faith that if
he's he's got all the raw ability not a
lot of tape
and it didn't work out at lsu and then
it kind of fell apart at a second stop
at kentucky
can he get it right in dallas to the nfl
when things get harder that's the
question everyone has
bobby brown just taken by the rams tell
me what you like about them yeah the
rams finally made a good pick so that's
a good sign
yeah the rams finally got it right they
woke up from the malibu house and had
some coffee and shook off the hangover
and took a good football player so
bobby brown listen just a big body in
the middle of the field i really like
this dude honestly
true nose tackle incredible incredible
power there's some film out there where
he's just throwing guys on the ground
you just don't get a lot of true nose
tackles like this six foot four
321 pounds 34 and three quarter inch
arms under five
second 40 so he could scoot for a big
dude that's really really impressive
i thought he dominated against south
carolina that was the game that i turned
on and said man can somebody block this
guy you should start double teaming them
because one guy's not getting it done
but 20 years old going into training
camp really young guy the best
best football is ahead of him not the
quickest off the ball but so
so powerful that motor it comes and goes
but he's a big guy you don't want him on
the field for
90 percent of the snaps he went on the
field for 30 35 of the snaps
keep that stamina up keep him going
those flashes have incredible strength
and he runs sideline the sideline
320 pounds he's like no i'll chase from
the backside bobby brown
really really nice pick for a team that
needed one in the worst way
yeah i mean rams you know starting to
kind of stack up some what's their
ceiling next season
their ceiling is they they could
absolutely be a contender i mean there's
no reason i know the division is tough
i'm kind of a matt stafford stan like
everybody kind of forgets about him
detroit was pretty miserable place for
him unfortunately and of course as soon
as he leaves they have one of my
favorite drafts
i've ever seen from the lions i believe
in him with this rams offense going to
the next level
my question with the rams is when they
get hit with injuries
you need to hit on these picks bobby
brown's one the guys they took yesterday
i don't know and this has been a problem
for the rams for a couple years now so
the starting roster the starting guys
really good matt stafford going to score
a lot of points cam makers you got
yourself a big believer right here
i think the rams can be a really really
good football team a deep playoff team
next year but they got to stay healthy
yeah okay coming from the matt stafford
stan
i'm intrigued why matt stafford for you
it's just somebody that i think is much
better in detroit they never have a
thousand yard rusher
never has a run game it's tough for a
quarterback to to really thrive without
any any sell of the run so he's kind of
on his own
the offensive line wasn't bad but
they're receivers they've had some
talent they've also let a lot of that
talent go over the years yeah i mean you
had calvin johnson say at 29.
i'm good i'm done i've had enough that's
tough to swallow
i think when you look at it across the
board the lions stafford somebody that
in the right situation with sean mcvay
can be a superstar player i think he's
been a top 12 quarterback for a long
time
with mcveigh he could be a top six top
eight quarterback that's a big
difference in football that's like hey
we're winning eight to nine games a year
to hey we're making a run in the
playoffs so
for the rams right now man if they get
deshawn jackson healthy and they start
pushing the football down the field and
they sell that play-action run game a
lot
and they got the offensive line clicking
they're in good shape yeah and staffer i
mean for the past two years has been one
of the better performers off of play
action so
how excited do you think that makes sean
mcvay he's a perfect fit yeah perfect
yeah mcveigh saw that and said i'm
willing to go that's my guy
willing to give up whatever they want
yeah absolutely all right who is still
who is still kind of left today that we
need to have our eyes on
oh let's go to the board i mean we
talked about the guards trey smith and
deante brown
starting caliber guards truly they're
guys that just you know the the stamina
will be a big question with deontay
because he's such a big guy
but man he's got good feet for a big guy
sweet feet for a big guy so you look at
him
those are the two that really jump off
the page to me right now i like
i like jalen darden from texas gonna
that's a later name that's a little bit
of a sleeper name
you know i don't know what tylan wallace
is still doing up there i know he tore
his acl in 2019. you see acl tears like
anything these days guys come back from
them all the time
brevin jordan a limited tight end but he
can catch the ball
you know evan ingram is kind of a guy
that same style it's like hey we need
you in the middle of the field
we can use you out in the slot big slot
that's what brevin jordan does
i'm going to keep talking about patrick
johnson until he comes off the board i
just love the player
and then chuba hubbard i'm still i might
be the only chuba hubbard fan left in
the world i think shuba hubbard's a
great player he had an explosive 2019
season
he was hurt in 2020. don't use that
against them chuba hubbard can be
something in this league
all right we have okay with the 118th
pick in the draft the chargers
oh you oh i like the excitement okay
tell me why chris rump gets the ooh
he's a different kind of player right
he's not this big edge rusher that puts
his hand in the dirt at 260 pounds and
says i'm just gonna run right through
you now he's twitched up he's like a
kind of like a big running back playing
edge pass rusher very strange player to
watch but
you know a really really good role for
him he's a stand-up situational rusher
you don't want him on the field on the
early downs as a runner
i compared him to aaron maben who i know
didn't have the most successful career
in the nfl but that style of
i'm speedy around the corner i could be
used on stunts
listen also in this league where it's so
pass happy you see a lot of empty sets
you're going to get a player like rump
on the field a lot more than you're used
to seeing so situational guy
stand up good speed off the edge all
finesse in his game no power
uh the the crate the thing that was
crazy to me is that bend around the
corner he can really
turn that body and beat tackles with
that shoulder dip
and the only problem with him when
tackles get their hands on him it's kind
of over when you're lighter you're
lighter it's a little tough to live in
the trenches but chris rump he's someone
that could be a ten sack player i'll
call it like i say it
yeah now i also know anytime someone has
you react like that
you are definitely a big fan you said
chris rump and i got a an onomatopoeia
from you
that's right the patriots are selecting
ramandre
stevenson uh run on arby's after kane
negwan you i believe is how you
pronounce it went to the vikings tell me
about this pick
yeah so with stevenson this one kind of
makes me laugh because my player
comparison was legarrette blount
so teams teams take players that they've
already seen in the past they'd uh we've
we've succeeded with this player before
that's who he is he's legarrette blount
big bodied runner six foot 227 i think
he played at 235
but he's got light feet for a big guy i
had him in the fifth round he goes in
the fourth i don't nitpick like that
he fits their offense right there
patriots are good to take a running back
or two every single year they keep a
stable of backs going
so they always got a healthy guy no long
speed good power
dominated oklahoma state made them look
like it was pop warner you know
light feet and he played it a big weight
like i said tacklers bounce off him he
loves that stiff arm at the second level
you better watch and you see it right
there
if he's got you lined up in the second
level of the field you better tackle and
wrap around those hips because he'll
he'll knock your head off and i loved
that and that he was in great shape with
the senior bowl so
from andre stevenson another another
fantasy sleeper kind of guy
some more tweets pouring in love all the
tweets about naji harris such a
kind guy i think that he held his draft
party i believe at a
at a homeless shelter which is just
really amazing to see
every story that comes about out about
him is so positive
let's welcome in houston texans running
back and roll ties very own
mark ingram joining us on day three
draft wrap presented by
rocket mortgage mark you look like you
are in very sunny florida
not a bad place to be for the off season
right
yeah yeah yeah i've been training here
for like eight nine years in the off
season so
it's just a beautiful day in sunny south
florida so just
you know enjoy the weekend absolutely
now mark you have been in the league for
over 10 years now you have seen it all
so
there is no better person to talk to
about this
new wave of running backs entering the
nfl than you
so let's get to it let's go over some of
the best guys
taken in the best opportunities starting
with travis etienne
and the jaguars what do you see in him
man
i've been like travis ethan's game ever
since he was a true freshman at clemson
you know they've been playing bama a lot
so i've had a chance to you know see him
you know get better and improve since he
was a freshman so
i like his game he's runs with power he
runs with elusiveness he has a lot of
explosion he can come out the backfield
and catch the ball
um i think he's following pass
protection so for him to be down there
in jacksonville
i know they're trying to create identity
with trevor lawrence and you know
obviously establishing a run
i think they have a great young player
in travis etn
and i think he'll have a you know a long
career as a professional
and um yeah i think he's a good player
yeah definitely a great piece and really
cool to see this reunion happening
uh with him and trevor lawrence moving
on to javonte williams and the broncos
who does javonte
remind you of any specific players um
i like his game i saw some i saw some of
his games i seen his highlights
whether he's like 5 10 like 220 so he
kind of has
a stature like me or zeke amongst those
lines
but um you know i've seen him run you
know in between the tackles
um you know break tackles i've seen him
uh
make people miss with his agility spin
off people finish runs
so um you know he's strong he's powerful
um he has some good illusions
which is what you want as a running back
and then he has a speed to you know hit
long runs too
so um yeah with his stature 510 220
that's kind of like right around me and
z kind of like that type
um but you know every run has their own
kind of identity their own style
guy's my favor but every running back
has its own kind of personality
so um i'm looking forward to seeing what
he does as well in the league
yeah he's definitely one of those backs
that's just really exciting to watch so
i'm
looking forward to watching him in
denver i seen him jumping over people
spinning
all kinds of stuff exactly it's like a
video game
analog stick right man absolutely what
is it you press
you press the circle circle button and
that yeah circle button for the spin
yeah yeah absolutely so they're they're
definitely going to get a show um from
javonte
all right how can trey sermon help the
49ers
i mean the 49ers their identity was
being physical
playing good defense running the
football letting jimmy g
kind of like you know navigate the game
with you know the help of the run game
so uh him going to
san fran i think it just is a great fit
um
you know they want to run the ball they
do a lot of outside zone you know
they've had a lot of
running backs that had success over the
years monster
um you know amongst many others so
for him to go there be able to help that
offense be able to help that team they
have a physical identity on that team
so i think he'll bring um he pitched
that mold 100
um run strong runs fast he's jumping
over people too
i mean he went for like 300 yards he
wanted to play off games um that was
more than enough that i needed to see
so once i saw that i became a big fan
nice so i'm i'm sure you were happy to
see alabama's naji harris drafted to the
steelers
now he said during his press conference
that he can do
everything that le'veon bell did if not
better
now what have you seen in his game that
gives you the confidence to agree with
this
very lofty statement yeah i mean
no that's that's high confidence you
know what i mean but
i think he has the ability you know
le'veon did it at the highest level for
many years with the steelers
so uh what i've seen from naji is just
steady steady consistent improvement
over his career at alabama being able to
overcome different situations where he
was behind like uh
josh jacobs damian harris people like
that so just the consistency the
determination to drive
drive to get better and to improve
consistently each and every year
and this year i think it paid off huge
for him he was able to show us that he
could run the ball inside
run the ball outside come out of the
backfield won't run real routes run
choice routes
um pick up pass protection and i think
all of those things
um you know in total kind of helped him
be a first round draft pick and to have
a huge opportunity to go to the
pittsburgh steelers
and have a you know significant first
day impact so
i'm excited for him i've been watching
him his whole career it's one of my guys
i talked to him i told him i was proud
of him you know congratulations and all
that
i'm looking forward to seeing what he
does with pittsburgh because it's going
to be a huge opportunity for him
and the afc north they love running
backs they love physical football so
they needed it now i love it because i
mean above all
else he just seems like a really kind
dude and so
that's great to see in the league and
i'm sure all of you know the royal tide
fans were very very happy for him
yeah like he had that uh what a a draft
party at the homeless shelter or
something
yes yeah i mean that's character you
know what i mean that's character that's
high character that's high value that's
something you want on your team or
someone you want in your organization so
happy for him proud of him and they're
getting a great player and a great
person too
for sure now you have a bit of a bias
but
what school do you consider to be
running back university
i mean 1 000 is alabama we're everything
you
we're everything you you know
everybody's going to have their you know
debate you could debate your mama about
it you know what i mean
but uh we're definitely rbu 100 i mean
the proof is in the pudding
you just go back look over the past 10
years of running backs have come out in
the first round and have
had good careers and um have had made a
lot of big plays and
you know it's alabama man from 2009
to you know just last night i mean two
two nights ago you know with naji so um
it's just consistent this is consistent
every year
every year is consistent somebody else
will be up somebody else will be ready
and we'll be talking about another bama
back next year too okay but for running
back you if somebody made the argument
for i don't know
georgia or ellis what would you say i
mean what gives bama
the edge over those schools see
i love georgia i mean i have a i'm i'm
i'm a fan of their running backs lsu i'm
a fan of their running backs
you know i mean it's just it's just not
the same you know what i mean it's just
not the same you know
you got you know you got a list you got
eight minus list b
plus list you know i mean they could be
second or third place on the rbu list
but when it comes to number one
everybody knows hands down bama
bama bama through and through especially
as of recent you know i mean
you might wanna georgia people might
wanna go back to herschel walker or
you know something like that you know
what i mean but as far as recent
what have you done for me lately 100 000
velma
you know what i think i have to give it
to you which pains me as somebody who is
from the state of georgia but uh you
might you might be right
what about i mean big night for the wide
receivers and
the first draft nine are you guys also
wide receiver you
of course i mean the proof's going to
put once again you could say clemson you
can say lsu
but when you go back you know
consistently since
we got drafted in 2011 i mean julio
jones
um you know we got calvary jerry judy
waddle ruggs we just got devonta i mean
devonta smith
um many others too so
i'm sure i'm missing some people but i
mean just them five six right there
you know puts you at the top of the
cream of the crop you know what i mean i
respect you know clemson they got some
crazy receivers
that's doing great things in the league
lsu got some crazy receivers
you know jamar chase just went whatever
top four or whatever it was so
you know they got their stake to the
claim but um as far as consistency
production
and what have you done for me lately you
know it's got to be belmont
y receiver you rbu everything you
everything you okay last one for you
just because alabama is
so intriguing to me i mean in your
opinion how is alabama so equipped to
withstand nfl departures and still
dominate because very few schools
have you know mastered that that
flexibility that next man up mentality
how does alabama do it man i think
coach saban just creates this culture of
competition in this culture of
excellence
so although he has dogs playing for him
currently on his starting you know 22
players on offensive defense
he has someone just like that or even
better coming up behind them
he's always in the top five of
recruiting classes so he just
always is evaluating talent and um
and and evaluating talent and developing
talent
um consistently so that when you know
the starters leave
his uh playmakers leave who are going
first round second round third round
getting drafted
um you got someone that's stepping right
in who is hungry
and excited for their opportunity and
they want to prove what they're worth
and prove what their value is so
i think it's just a culture that coach
saban creates obviously his
ability to evaluate talent and develop
talent and
get everyone to buy in you know it's not
a me thing it's a wee thing
and i think that's just something that
coach saban does a great job of with the
culture at alabama
and uh that's why he's the goat that's
why he's consistently at the top
and every single year um we're looking
for championships and this championship
or busted bama if you get 12 wins you
don't win a championship
you're a forgotten team so you got to
win a championship at bama
now absolutely well mark ingram alum
of everything you thank you so much for
joining us
good luck this season and go enjoy the
good weather in florida
thank you taylor i always appreciate you
having me
all righty browns fans enjoying the nfl
draft so
far got some tweets brown's on the clock
uh welcoming james hudson to cleveland
dog pound they're ready like listen guys
you fell up short last
season we're trying to get the pieces to
make it to the super bowl again
dog pound definitely has some of the
more um fierce
fans i would say in the nfl right very
passionate
i mean i'll tell you a little something
we did the mock draft special and
i gave the browns like a linebacker in
round one and boy i learned real quick
they wanted a corner and they got their
corner in round one so good for the dog
yeah connor is like blocked by all of
browns
i don't block people so they have to
block me all right well speaking of the
browns
very excited to welcome in cleveland.com
brown's beat writer mary kay
cabot to the show super excited to talk
everything cleveland with you mary kay
so you know it is very clear that the
browns entered into this offseason
wanting to
upgrade their defense with their free
agent signings with some of their draft
selections
up to this point what grade would you
give the browns in terms of just
upgrading their d you know what i i
think you have to give them an a they
really got
two first-round picks uh two guys that
they had targeted in the first round in
greg newsom and then coming back
and getting jeremiah owusu koromora
uh in the second round they were so
excited to get him they traded up to get
him all they had to do was move back a
little bit in the fourth round to secure
that pick
uh it turned out really really well for
them they are ecstatic
he's going to be able to do so much in
this defense they've overhauled the
complete
defense this year and it should be
something else
now you know covering the past was one
of cleveland's big weaknesses
last season will we see an immediate
impact you know from greg newsome and
jeremiah usa coramura addressing that
concern
oh yeah i think you'll see an immediate
impact when you draft guys that high
they're gonna they're going to start at
some point now it might not be
week one uh but within within a few
weeks you could you will see those guys
uh contributing in a big way and then
eventually
starting games for the cleveland browns
this year that's what happens when you
draft guys that
again both were targeted in the first
round so
they bring speed they bring hustle they
bring disruption
versatility and it won't be long before
they're on the field
now before we welcomed you in connor and
i were talking about the intensity and
passion
you know that is the cleveland browns
fan base
as you kind of gauge the temperature of
the fans how do they feel
about the picks so far the the browns
have acquired
oh they're over the moon i mean browns
fans hope always springs eternal here in
bronze
town and it's no different this year but
with them coming off of a playoff
campaign going to the afc divisional
round
and giving the chiefs a really good run
for their money
uh the fans are just sky-high right now
so excited
i mean this is a completely different
defense than the one that struggled at
times last year
and now i think they feel they have one
that that can give some of these
excellent offenses like the chiefs a
real run for their money now the chiefs
of course
uh went out and upgraded their offensive
lines so they have a counter attack uh
but the browns
really feel like they've done a lot to
get to that next level they want to go
further into the playoffs and obviously
get to the super bowl and that's all
fans can think about right now
now on the other side of the ball
brown's drafted anthony schwartz in the
third round
wide receiver out of auburn tons of
speed did catch some people by surprise
though
why does this pick make sense for the
browns
well just as you mentioned the speed
he's got world-class speed 4.25 it's an
element that they really need to have
when odell beckham jr got hurt last year
they did not have the speed that they
needed
and so uh absolutely they you know they
feel like they have something now
that they can really hurt defenses with
stretch the field and strike a little
fear
uh into some of these defensive backs
it felt like just based on the twitter
sphere once the
browns announced that they were going to
be acquiring anthony
schwartz there was some model
speculation you know people felt like
okay is this just kind of you know
a different type of odell type player is
there any
credence you know to the to those
thoughts or do you think that it's a
little bit of a reach and this is just
them adding another offensive weapon
uh that that's definitely a reach it's
just them adding another offensive
weapon i mean they do have to start
planning for life after jarvis landry
and
odell beckham jr but that's not going to
happen for a while those guys will
be here this year and and they will have
a very dynamic
and in some cases scary receiving core
especially now again
at this speed so uh there
are a lot of weapons on this football
team it's going to be explosive
offensively and defensively and also
multiple on both sides of the ball
yeah i spoke to odell two days ago he
seemed like he was in really great
spirits continuing to progress in his
rehab
any update um on how that's going for
him
he looks great he posts a lot of videos
of himself on social media
it looks like he is you know full out
sprinting
uh you know he's doing all kinds of
things he's running he's cutting
and i would expect that he will be 100
by training camp and you'll probably see
an excellent and amazing odell this year
yeah absolutely always exciting to watch
him now you know we hear the word
identity tossed around
a lot in football and baker mayfield
recently said that early in the season
last year
the browns didn't have a true identity
um what do you feel is their identity
now
well you know as i mentioned before
their identity is
uh is to be multiple and to be extremely
explosive
and uh and and that's that's what they
will be i mean this is something that
uh you know teams are not gonna know
where to find some of these guys on
defense because miles garrett can move
all around
jadav and clowny can move all around uh
it'll be hard to tell whether
somebody's a safety or a linebacker
it'll be
hard to id those guys if you're the
quarterback and they're just going to do
so many things on both sides of the ball
that will make them difficult to defend
and tough to stop
absolutely thank you so much mary kay
have an amazing time covering the browns
this season i'm sure
as always it will be exciting and thank
you so much for joining us
i will thanks for having me absolutely
all right this year's draft coverage is
made possible by rocket mortgage are you
a top draft pick who needs to buy a new
home and a new place
and doesn't know where to start rocket
can
check out the rocket mortgage home
buyer's guide for articles
tips and tools to make the home buying
process as smooth
as this ad read all right connor
yeah you know what can i say what can i
say
all right now speaking of smooth odell
beckham jr you heard mary kay talking
about it some you see the browns
tweeting about
who is joining him in cleveland what
odella
gonna see this year we know he is an
elite wide receiver and when he is good
it changes the entire game
it really does and i think the great
thing for o'dell is he's in a situation
where the quarterback has clearly taken
the next step
not the step to being a leap but the
step to being the guy good right
the offensive line it looks right he's
got talent around him they know how to
develop the run game they know how to
obviously another team that uses play
action another team that
is trying to set up that vertical attack
that's where odell comes in
i think with odell he's somebody that
can be relied on as the star
but you'd rather give him some help like
anyone else where you can
sell the run have the defense inch up
get him working over the top baker's
getting a little bit more confident i
don't think baker ever lacks confidence
but now he oh yeah he has got some guns
yeah we know that
but i think he really needs to just let
it go and to get odell working give him
a chance so
when odell's healthy we know the
difference maker he is all right let's
look at some recent draft picks that
were
feeling dangerous like mr baker mayfield
a lot happening in day three
lots of excitement on the twitter sphere
as well but all right
some of your guys yes so i'll you know
i'll start with shuba hubbard and i'll
work my way backwards
i think when you look at chuba he was
overlooked because
if he declared after 2019 where he was
an absolute monster on the field at
running back
he probably would have been a day two
pick a no-brainer day two they might
have been stuck in the second round
track speed
good outside runner good burst very
upright reminds me of darren mcfadden a
lot actually when you look at that track
speed that home run speed
he can get to the outside he can make
you miss okay pass catcher
not great yet really struggled in pass
protection that's why he's still on the
board
he's going to be a change-of-pace runner
early on i
love this fit in carolina because he's
behind christian mccaffrey now so you're
not relying on super hubbard
to come in and be the guy you can work
him in five six touches a game
get him going on screens get him working
in the flat get him on the outside run
game so
for chuba hubbard good for him to come
off the board in this spot
somebody that i valued a little bit
higher than that right i looked at chuba
and thought he was a top 100 player
so this is a really good pick for
carolina and they you know
we saw what happened to mccaffrey
running backs get hurt totally you need
a number two and a number three
he comes in right away as the number two
there and there's also i mean you can't
underestimate just the advantage that
comes with being able to learn from
someone like christian mccaffrey as well
absolutely and mccaffrey is you know a
little similar in a sense where he came
in and it's like hey you know
we're going to have to pick up the blitz
you're going to have to get better in
pass pro
we know you're an explosive explosive
talent mccaffrey may be the best pass
catching back in the entire nfl
right now that's something that chuba
could work on a little bit so we'll go
back we'll work our way back to board
here a little bit
i mean zach mcpherson was a guy he goes
to the eagles at corner
that every time i talk to a coach or a
scout and said hey who's your day three
guy this name came up over and over
again he could play inside he could play
outside
he could play special teams very very
athletic from a family of athletes
there's like six high-level athletes in
their family it's insane
transfer from penn state so he has a lot
of reps under his belt
mcpherson's a guy that the eagles they
need to help a corner and now you get
just this utility man right if one of
your outside corners gets hurt you can
come in and play if one of your inside
corners get hurt he can come in and man
the slot
you know he's going to play special
teams week in and week out with that
kind of speed that kind of explosiveness
whether it's as a gunner or even as a
guy on the punt team
as a blocker so mcpherson he's got some
ball skills he's got the speed
this is a really good value pick on day
three here for the eagles they're really
figuring it out with this trap so far to
be honest with you taylor i mean you get
devonta smith you get landon dickerson
you get mcpherson the first two guys are
high end starters i mean pro bowl level
starters right away
mcpherson more of a role player and
that's okay in this spot yep
absolutely that's what i was going to
say it seems like the the eagles are
really one of the winners of this draft
uh i know another pick is in right now
tampa bay buccaneers wide receiver not
like tom brady needs any more
toys but they've got jalen that's a good
one though
okay tell me about that i mean this is a
good one it's unfair
tom brady just has the world in his hand
i don't even want to talk about it yeah
i'm with you there trust me i know
a man that ruined part of my childhood
so you know as a jets fan growing up in
new york once upon a time
listen jalen darden from north texas
explosive one of the best separators in
this trap
slot only kind of player although i have
seen him win on the outside but
i think at the nfl level he's going to
play the slot for them you don't really
got to get on the field in this offense
they got godwin they got mike evans they
brought ab
back they got scottie miller i mean the
rich get richer that's what i've been
saying to a keeve all weekend and
he really liked that line because you
see it happen with the good teams over
and over again
jalen darden i thought he could be an
impact player this screams draft and
stash to me he reminds me of darnell
mooney that went to the bears last year
one of the more impressive
rookie deep threats from last season
thought he had good hands once again he
just gets open you want to turn on his
best tape i like to give the fans that
go on youtube go wherever you can watch
the game
middle tennessee he made them look
foolish childish i would even say
okay really what about him in that
matchup nobody can run with him
fastest guy on the field nobody can run
with him the release is at the line of
scrimmage winning vertically
uh winning across the field on the drag
routes it really there was no answer
they had no answer for him
all day so i think with jalen darden man
he's your fifth wide receiver i mean
come on i thought he could have came in
and been a number three somewhere right
away
and when you're the bucks you can afford
this you don't have needs you just think
the best player on the board yeah you
have
everything that you need because you
have tom
brady all right the rams pick us in
uh sticking with the defense for the
rams picking up a corner robert rochelle
yeah without robert interesting player
right an interesting athlete uh
i know he was on feldman's freaks list
over the summer because he had been
timed at 438 with a 41 inch vertical so
yeah a long corner 61197 i had him in
the fifth round so this is this is right
where you expect him to go
a little bit raw of a player in
technique but he's got that long ability
where you can expect him to press at the
line of scrimmage
the speed to be a man coverage corner
and i think you just saw it right there
i just think he needs a little bit more
instincts turning around to play the
football in the air that's the one
problem with robert rochelle right now
and
guess what taylor uh they don't they
don't get any slower in the nfl they
only get faster so
yeah this is a draft and stash corner
where you you think you can develop this
guy to play on the outside across from
jalen ramsey in the future
it's just not going to happen this year
but when you talk about you know these
draft and stash players
what is that shelf life you know at what
point during the station you'd be like
okay you are ready that development
has occurred it's time to go you get two
years you know and i remember having
breakfast with a former super bowl gm at
one time and one of the funniest i'll
never forget this i don't really keep
all these things stored in my brain but
he said to me
he goes conor he goes the about the
second day of otas not training camps
second day otas
you know if a guy's going to make it in
the nfl or not he goes and more
importantly he goes you know if you made
a gigantic mistake and i was like
really from otas he goes it's even worse
that not only you know it he goes every
single player in that locker room knows
it
really so it's uh you know sink or swim
in the nfl yeah and that makes
sense it's probably fairly innate all
right next pig is in
uh the ravens are up i believe
wide receiver god i mean oh we've got a
woo
thank god connor's happy tell me why
you're happy
the ravens have become one of my
favorite teams in the nfl in terms of
what they do from a scouting perspective
they do what everyone else is too dumb
to do and that's draft good football
players when they shouldn't be on the
board anymore tylan wallace
one of the most productive college
football receivers in the last three
years
deep threat not the biggest guy you see
the ball tracking there he can really
play the football in the air
once again not the biggest guy he's
going to get jammed to the line of
scrimmage and he's going to have to
learn to work through that
baltimore had this problem this
offseason where they couldn't get a top
receiver to sign there
and they said you know what we're not
worried about that because we know how
to scout we know how to draft this is a
franchise that
has legendary scouting roots with ozzie
newsome eric decosta learned under him
and has taken over that reign
they got rashad bateman in round one now
you get tylen wallace a round two player
for me
this late in round four round four
lamar jackson's getting some help and
thank god everybody talks about all
these young quarterbacks needing help
lamar jackson won an mvp and he hasn't
had you know they have good tight ends
they have a great offensive line a great
run game
but he's not throwing to number one wide
receivers all the time so now you got
bateman you got wallace you got
hollywood there
they have a nice group of wide receivers
that complement each other quite well
does thailand wallace remind you of
anybody any comp for him
let's pull up the board i know i got one
i think it was christian kirk actually
spoiler alert connor always has one
yeah i typically usually do have one we
get later on in day three i'll start the
you know it'll get a little crazy
christian kirk was the comp for me knows
how to win down the field
uh that 6973 cone really shifty player
you know under 200 pounds
once i said they're going to press them
at the line of scrimmage but you want to
turn on that tape the deep threat
the play against texas the game against
texas he lit it up
absolutely lit it up he just knows how
to win down the field and he's done it
for three years so there's no like oh
one year wonder
or hey he's coming off injury it's no we
we've seen it we've seen it before and
after
yeah he's he's consistent yeah uh
raven's offense clicking
this season clicking it's and they
needed this they really needed this you
know they added kevin seitler one of the
most underrated editions for the
offensive line in the entire offseason
the giants had to let him go because of
cap casualty
the ravens say hey let's get you here
and it's a friendly offensive line
scheme what i mean by that it's a lot of
man blocking a lot of power run game
they have a type there in baltimore and
you know they execute it very well
and it also is friendly because even if
we let a free rusher in nobody touches
lamar jackson lamar jackson is great at
extending the play
great as an open field runner but now
they got receivers where lamar is going
to dial it back and say
i don't always have to be the hero and
run i can keep my eyes downfield like
the greats do
like rogers you know like russ like
mahomes yeah keep my eyes downfield and
find the big chunk play through the air
and he i it's really interesting because
every year you see him get better but my
favorite thing about lamar
you can always tell he's having fun out
there he's just really really how many
haters he has
i know it's really wild because he's
also just a nice guy right
all right next week seems like we're
talking about the brownies a lot but
they have drafted a defensive tackle
tommy and i do not want to mess up his
name
tommy i want to say yeah uh togiyai
togiai
there you go so that's with the player
cops you also got to write in the
pronunciation yeah
he's like i'm an expert yeah by next
year you're gonna have all you're gonna
have this down like nothing you could do
it in your sleep but with tokyo they
didn't have to go too far right ohio
state player fourth round grade
uh this is actually good value this is a
little this is a little late for him i
think 40 reps on the bench so i
literally wrote in the scouting report
40 reps on the bench he's a lad in all
caps just an absolute unit this guy
crushes people at the point of attack
really good against the run game big
hustle player
strong hands he understands leverage in
the middle there you see him playing
shade nose
he can play true nose he can play three
tech he's an interior rotational player
for early downs so for the browns
they lost sheldon richardson right
that's something that now sheldon's a
different player sheldon's gonna get up
field and rush the passer but with tokyo
i think he could develop into that down
the stretch you just want rotational
pieces right now for that front
that just is loaded with talent it's
unfair right now so this is a nice pick
and you know we heard mary kay give her
grade of the brown so far
seems like they're stacking up some
what's your grade oh that's good for the
browns right now i would say they're at
an a
even an a minus i think newsome you're
going to worry a little bit about his
injuries week to week in round one but
owusu coramoa i mean good lord that was
a tremendous pick in round two he's a
round one player now you get together
here
brad's been a nice job yeah absolutely
all right don't forget you know for all
the fans out there
there are some some goodies that are
going around continue to keep
that in mind you share your video
breakdown
of your team's draft in the nfl draft
community on the br
app you see this swag you see the black
and white the classic look we can send
you
some br grid iron gear straight to your
home
[Music]
i used to have a landlord who thought he
could fix everything here we go again
he could not
when you need to throw in the towel on
renting rocket cam
you got any tape
[Music]
all right joining us now is the
athletics vic tafer to discuss
everything raiders vic we are so happy
to have you here now before we get to
the draft and gruden and everything in
between
gonna get right to it what are you
hearing about aaron rodgers
uh not much i think that's a long shot
for the raiders i think um
you know when you got like that you have
to plan for as far as salary cap wise
and cash wise and
and what would take to get them so it's
kind of a last-minute thing i'm not sure
the packers want uh derek carr back
either so that's also probably a problem
if this were to happen so
i wouldn't if you're a raider fan i
wouldn't get too excited about aaron
rodgers
uh wearing silver and black anytime soon
yeah well you know i had to ask but also
had to be a fairly exciting day for you
and randomly
you know the raiders are kind of thrown
into the bowl of potentials right
i'm not sure that's what i would use
exciting but um yeah definitely it's
definitely like a truck uh running over
you in the middle of the street but um
yeah the raiders are always in the
middle of it because um you know i think
john gruden is like a kind of guy if you
want to talk about him and
possibilities so i think players be
excited about playing for him and
just it's a kind of a the character that
he is makes it uh
all more fun to be part of the national
storyline
yeah absolutely okay well switching over
to the draft tell me what was your level
of shock you know when the raiders
grabbed o lineman alex leatherwood with
the 17th overall pick
i was surprised i definitely um i wasn't
shocked as a little strong because i had
him going to them in the second round so
i thought it was a good pick
just maybe 30 picks too early i think he
was a good fit he's probably the best
run blocking
a tackle in the draft so that's what
they want to do so i mean
the the name itself wasn't surprising
but where he was picked
i thought it was a little high yeah i
mean the raiders brass continues to talk
about how
impressed uh they were with him what do
you feel like they saw in alex that
gave him the confidence to pick him um
at 17.
the big thing was that run blocking
presents he's a huge guy he has pretty
good feet and definitely some power good
hands so
i think they want a guy that can plug in
a right tackle from day one
i thought he was that guy i just think
um yeah when you're
going through the draft process and then
your spouse and your coaches their jam
kind of fall in love with the guy i can
see where you want that guy
if you want to try and trade back wait a
minute are we sure we're going to
miss our guy if you trade back so i can
see you kind of go into your own head
and kind of
predetermine where you're going to grab
a guy when he can
yeah okay so i have a tweet here vic it
says the great big tafer mocked the
raiders drafting and trevor morgan alex
leatherwood back in march
he had the rounds flipped but we still
owe him praise on the next state of the
nation podcast
uh can you please tell me what's going
to happen in my life next year see
seems like you've got the predictions
down nah just lucky that's my pr guide
to sean i appreciate that but
yeah i just you know you kind of think
what the raiders is they definitely will
surprise you but the one thing they will
do is they'll draft for need they
definitely won't
the whole best player available thing is
kind of a myth anyway but for them
especially
they knew they needed a right tackle on
the safety it was just a matter of when
they were to get each one and i had it
flipped but that felt pretty secure
about
them getting those two guys uh at some
point
so what should fans expect from trayvon
morrig the safety
i think it's pretty good i think you but
for me it was the best safety on the
board he's kind of a classic center
fielder kind of guy you can
run all the roster receivers take good
angles he uh i guess
the phrases of ball hawk you know he
makes good plays in the ball so
i think they were surprised that two
safeties would be for him in the draft i
was surprised
they did a nice thing with it but
trading up to get him so i think he's
the perfect fit
for what they need all right now besides
having just
now one of the best names in the nfl
divine diablo
um what impact is he going to have
well he's kind of you look at him in
college and everyone thinks oh my god
it's cam chancellor
they have gus bradley they got you guys
own version of the cam chancellor
i think so that was the reaction i think
but i think they have him more
uh lined up as a um linebacker that's
what i'll be a spot more of a linebacker
than safety
kind of a how you can move around a
little bit because today in the nfl you
don't really need positions these guys
big guys who can run what you need and
that's what that's what he is
okay um tell me any replacements uh for
jonathan abrams
uh no i think he's i mean he's the guy
right now obviously they brought up carl
joseph i think maybe he's a
insurance policy but uh they they're
confident that abram will uh
get some experience and kind of some
maturity and maybe not always go for the
big play kind of
he's definitely a good player in the run
packages but he has to work better on
passing situations as far as
responsibilities not blowing coverages
and kind of staying home
where we're supposed to be in
assignments
all right now we all know john gruden
tends to get a lot of heat and criticism
for the way that he drafts but as
someone who covers the team so closely
do you feel like there is
a bit of a method to the madness
um i do not i think
i think john is pretty much kind of uh
he might
feel really strongly about one thing on
monday and tuesday
tops it opposite direction so i think
he's a guy who kind of goes
by his emotions which is probably good
and bad but um players
you know we saw both russell wilson and
now you know aaron rodgers
their so-called list of what places they
wanted to go i think that the raiders
were top of both those lists because of
john gruden so
players love his energy i think they
love the one definitely still one of the
top offensive minds in the league so
there's still a lot there to like about
john gruden just like it's been kind of
topsy-turvy the first three years so i
think we're waiting to see what happens
uh
this year absolutely well vic i am so
impressed
with the predictions like i said i'm
gonna i'm gonna hit you up winning to
psychic
so um know that that is coming and thank
you so much for joining us here on our
jeff wrap show
all right take care have a great one
all right some raiders tweets pouring in
uh johnny saying the raiders draft is
pretty impressive and i'm happy no big
names but sometimes you don't need big
names to win at all oh look at that
johnny yeah and that's true
he said let's see how this goes like i
said diablo divine
greatest name ever getting a lot of love
for him on twitter
um fans saying they have never been more
proud i mean vegas is going to be
putting on a show
which is really exciting connor it
really is and and they go get guys that
are their brand of football right you
heard them talk about leatherwood
he's just kind of hey i'm going to line
up against you and and good luck because
i'm a tough guy i'm a drive blocker i'm
a bully and an iron man he's somebody
that just doesn't miss time and it's
played guard and tackle and then
you know you heard vic bring up trayvon
mary that's just a tremendous selection
he's the best safety in the draft the
best cover safety in the draft
uh he could play the slot he could play
he played a lot of too high in college
but he's got the ability to play single
high
and make plays on the ball yeah
absolutely okay you know what speaking
of some plays the fans want to know
what bets they should place and there is
no
better person to talk about that within
our very own
kelly stewart kelly it is so great to
see you i know you
love college football how fun just these
past couple days been for you
it's actually been really awesome taylor
to see these guys
their dreams coming true and also
hearing all the rumors all of the fun
stuff going on but yeah it's been
incredible to see
what the next nfl season is going to
look like with some of these rookies
coming in
all right so let's talk about those
rookies let's talk about who's you know
really getting things going there in the
betting world who has defensive rookie
of the year potential kelly
well we all can have different story
lines here but one i
really like is micah parsons now
unfortunately he is the betting favorite
at plus
400 but he's going to the dallas cowboys
as
a linebacker and this dallas cowboys
defense was bottom five last year
just absolutely atrocious so he's got to
start right away and i think he's going
to be an integral part of this defense
again he is the favorite at plus 400 so
it kind of makes me think
you know i don't love it i don't want to
put a ton of money on it
but i do believe he's going to win the
award if you're looking for more of a
long shot though
jc horn at 14-1 i think it's kind of
going to be a sneaky one
for carolina absolutely and jc horn out
of georgia shout out to georgia
um what did you think about patrick
certainly do you think that he would be
um
more likely to win defensive rookie of
the year well since connor
talked about being a fan of the jets
when he was a kid when i was a kid
i was a denver broncos fan so i am very
happy
for the denver broncos certain one of
the best cornerbacks i
have a concern though with him and how
he's going to fit into that broncos
defense right away
i hope he is a breakout star but as far
as his value goes from a betting
perspective i thought 10-1 was just a
little too short
okay so you switch over to offensive
rookie of the year
tell me your pick i think the whole
world thinks it's gonna be trevor
lawrence in jacksonville and that's the
unfortunate part
he is the betting favorite at three to
one but i'm going
way down the list now i know a wide
receiver hasn't won it since odell
beckham jr almost 10 years ago
but i'm gonna take a long shot at 33-1
and that is rashad bateman
of the baltimore ravens i think the
ravens
we all know them as this rushing team
but i believe
he's going to be able to help them
stretch the field and get some of those
deep play action routes i think he's
going to see a
ton of targets this year and at 33-1 i
think he holds a ton of value
okay tell me about kyle pitts's chance
to
maybe win that award no kyle pitts i
definitely think it's going to be
in the mix but since i gave out such a
favorite for defensive player of the
year i wanted to find a longer shot
somebody i really thought had a chance
but yes kyle pitts is definitely worth a
look now absolutely okay
so which player got the biggest boost in
mvp odds because of the drafts kelly
i'm gonna catch a lot of flack for this
uh-oh i'm ready
i love it who was ready who was cheering
so hard for this team last year the
washington football team
made me a ton of money i love ron rivera
we call him riverboat ron because he
loves to gamble
and what are they gambling on this year
a veteran quarterback who has a ton of
weapons this is a team
that i do think is playoff bound a
hundred to one now this is a total long
shot this is a flyer of a bet
this doesn't mean he's got probably a
very small chance to win it but i really
like ryan
fitzpatrick i know it sounds really
crazy but wow looking
down through that list you can make a
case of course for tom brady
depending on if aaron rodgers retires or
goes to a team you can make a case
for tons of these guys but i just think
there's something special about
fitzmagic where he's been able to plug
and play
on several teams and i think what he's
going to be able to do with ron rivera
could be really uh i think it could be
really exciting to see
so very long shot at 101 but since you
guys are giving me the opportunity to
gamble let's gamble
yeah now kelly i will say i was not
expecting a ryan fitzpatrick
to be the person that you named there
i really wasn't no of course of course
not look i i do think that it is a
very very very slim chance that's why
the odds are what it is but
there's something special about this
washington football team they have a ton
of weapons we know this defense
last year stepped up big time and
they're in the nfc
east we know this conference or excuse
me this division always struggles
i think that they have an outside shot
to get into the playoffs and
get kind of ryan fitzpatrick's name out
there as far as the talking point goes
oh i love it i love it okay any bets you
would put in right now for future
so i was looking at the super bowl and
unfortunately i don't ever place
bets without getting through free agency
while the draft is super exciting
we know that the chances of all these
kids panning out and playing
at a high level for a significant period
of time is slim
and so i have to wait and see before i
start making my bets now last year
let's use tom brady as an example as
soon as he got announced to the bucks
the lines just plummeted so if you have
some good inside information
you know that aaron rodgers is going to
be a bronco or as you guys were talking
about a long shot for him to be a raider
whatever that may be get those bets in
now but i'm not usually confident until
about july
to start making those rather whether
they're
super bowl futures to win their division
regular season wins any of those i
usually wait
and sometimes you can lose the value but
i feel like it's better than taking the
risk
at holding a terrible number i will
thank you so much
kelly you are always the go-to for all
things betting we appreciate your time
here on the draft rap show thanks so
much
thank you taylor see you soon
all right we want to take a quick moment
to shout out our sponsor
rocket mortgage do you want to see your
loan options adjust payments and closing
costs online
in real time rocket can with all that
helpful information together in one
place i guess you could say that rocket
mortgage is kind of like the uh connor
rogers
of the home buying world wow want to
lock in
an interest rate today rocket can't we
had to give you some love
connor rogers hey but speaking of my
second
favorite rogers aaron rodgers we have we
have an update
all right here is a bombshell from
charles robinson who reports that aaron
rodgers wants the packers to
fire their g in there you go
i said was a little uh friction there
and probably more with the front office
than the coach
there you go i think this is a power
play for one of the most powerful
players in all of sports right
in the nba the pl the players really you
know control everything and i think nfl
players kind of turn their eyes and
we're like wait a minute like if i'm
that good why can't i do that and we
heard akeeb say it
akeeb said in his 10th year he realized
he doesn't have to go somewhere he
didn't want to
when he was traded and keep was a
credible player
aaron rodgers is a quarterback a star
mvp quarterback hall of fame this is
taylor this is an unprecedented stare
down
i mean they're going to have to choose
what would i mean
the gm of the team who to be fair to
goody
he's made some really nice roster moves
over the years
i believe he was the one that did hire
matt lafleur who's had a lot of success
in two years
at the same time i think i know who i'm
picking
uh totally i mean okay do you watch the
show the office yes
you remember when michael scott and
dwight and andy it's the
and they have the guys yes and they're
like okay
who's going in what world do you choose
any option over aaron rodgers i mean you
can't the only thing i can
they really really think that
jordan love is the future and they're
comfortable with getting a godfather
offer for aaron rodgers
they'd have to really think it's hard to
have that political power
i can't see political power over aaron
rodgers yeah i just can't i
i that's a this is an unprecedented
situation
i ultimately think that if rogers is
truly saying
i will stay i don't have a problem
with matt lafleur which i don't think he
does honestly i really do think this is
all about
his you know future replacement
being drafted in the first round i think
ultimately you have to roll with rogers
but we're gonna see how it plays out i
mean i think aaron feels slighted and
sometimes i wonder
is it just that they picked jordan love
in the first round or is it more that
he wasn't even brought in to discuss it
i i think you hit the nail on the head
with the latter i think it's a situation
where
you have a player that has you know won
a super bowl is a superstar
playing at a high level the packers are
traditionally obviously a team that you
know they're a little early
aaron rodgers knows this because he was
the guy behind brett favre for a couple
of years
so this isn't news with the packers
organization but in today's nfl
it doesn't really work like that patma
homes is the one guy everybody goes oh
you have to sit this quarterback because
pat
patrick sat for a year and was a star
it's rare it doesn't happen a lot
so you look at their recent first
rounders i mean where's the help
for the guy yeah where's the help and i
know they've done a good job
overall like you have devante adams who
wasn't a first round pick
but once again they've been building the
defense there's nice picks here kenny
clark jair alexander great players
i mean they really really are but once
again you look at it i'm sure there's a
part of rogers that said
man you took my replacement like i could
live with you taking guys on the other
side of the ball
that are going to get me back on the
field that are going to stop drives
that are going to win us games that are
going to make things happen and make
life a little easier for the offense
the guy behind me in the first round you
traded up for him
yeah that tells me how you really wanted
it you didn't just go hire my
replacement because you found someone
that fell into your lap
you looked for my replacement that's the
difference
yeah i mean this i think is going to be
quite
the saga just as the offseason but it
feels like things are moving
so quickly right now we might see
something come to fruition
in a week or so yeah things move quickly
yeah you hear a lot of
leaks from the team that hey you know
and obviously vik said it's
raiders fans slow down this isn't
happening and he would know he knows
everything about the raiders i'll tell
you that he's been doing it for long
enough
now a lot can change one phone call it
really really can
it i mean it really now the problem for
the packers is
they're a team that has built a roster
that is contending for a super bowl
right now so do you trade your best
player
to start the future but you don't you
didn't get any picks this year
for it you got to wait until next year
what do you do
you're treading water this year treading
water in the nfl is the worst place to
be
if you're going to be bad be awful be
jacksonville be the jets
pick one and two blow it up trade your
stars get a million picks
start over you don't want to you don't
want to jeff fisher it right you don't
want a seven and nine you don't
you don't want to just sit there and be
like well we don't know because we got
veterans that should be going for the
super bowl now
we got a quarterback that needs two
years before he's ready we got a coach
that probably wants to win right now
because he's just won the last two years
this is such a difficult situation no i
mean in the nfl
treading water is drowning that's
exactly right they are slowly though
yeah which is which is a little worse
which is literally not fun
yeah okay so these are their editions
for this year
you could see i mean they're they're
trying to do aaron right right now
it's a little bit like hey man turn on
the draft yeah
turn on bleacher report see those grades
they gave them day two picks
josh myers they needed a replacement for
corey lindsay he's a center that like
corey lindsey ohio state
really really nice state two pick plug
and play starter moves well
amari rogers reggie wayne said he's a
better version of randall cobb i was
like okay let's go
mart rogers the wide receiver built like
a running back can play the middle of
the field tough guy good after the catch
he'll be aaron rodgers you know second
best friend not named davonte adams
eric stokes it was a reach for me but
he's got all the all the athleticism to
be a good corner and you know once again
that's a player that's helping the
defensive side of the ball they needed
some help at corner for the future
you're right taylor it's like day two
they woke up and like man we really
pissed them off this time how do we make
good on this
yeah and it's like they sent like a
small bouquet of flowers
rather than like going to the door and
being like i'm sorry yeah and they also
need to send like
80 billion gardens it's like this one
thing of flowers is not gonna work this
guy is really upset if there's one thing
we know he's
he's headstrong he will be there ten
toes down he's gonna do jeopardy he
doesn't care
yeah he's like listen y'all need to
figure out what is going to work for me
because i am ready to
stick out this entire time all right
let's go to some recent picks
um in the draft at the moment all right
saints
drafting notre dame quarterback ian book
tell me your thoughts on ian book
yeah i wasn't sure if he would be
drafted now i think when you look at it
you know obviously senior bowl player
add him at 203 so i thought he'd be a
sixth or a seventh round player he goes
a little early here
i'll go ahead yeah absolutely i mean
when you look at ian book it's it's kind
of funny he's like the poorest man's
version of breeze right and that
i want to make sure people know i have
no drew brees expectations for ian book
but
how he succeeds is for a smaller
quarterback bouncing around the pocket
not a very strong arm but accuracy and
touch throws and
knowing where he has to get the football
a tough guy a good leader you got those
notre dame hog mollies in front of you
you better get some respect in the
locker room he got the respect he won a
lot of ball games for notre dame so
ian book once again not the biggest arm
i don't know if he has the arm for the
nfl
but he's that i can manage things i know
where the ball needs to go i can take
care of the football
i'm not the best athlete i'm not the
biggest guy with the strongest arm but i
could do all the little things right so
i projected him as a
you know third string maybe long-term
backup if things work out
and we saw a fun adam chapter tweet
saying drew brees is going to be calling
some games in her name and ian book's
actually going to be there so it's a bit
of a
bit of a switch yeah i guess so i think
i was like all right adam
sean peyton's got yeah adam's just
trying to make it work right now on day
three like the rest of us i totally get
it he's like i gotta find something to
talk about here
until the kentucky derby or whatever it
is on later so when you look at it right
here a couple good players off the board
uh you know we talked about togei i
think he's somebody that makes a lot of
sense ian book a
little bit of a head scratcher there
right there you know when you look at
weaver from pit edge rusher
not the most athletic guy but more i can
control the point of attack and set the
edge and stop the run and maybe develop
these past
pass rush traits i'd like to see him
counter a little bit more on the inside
to set up that outside move he has going
tennessee they gave bud dupree a lot of
money but they're just getting another
edge pass rusher in the building
marco wilson one of the best testing
athletes in the entire draft but his
film was the struggle bus at times
some head scratching penalties i don't
know if you remember taylor he's the guy
that picked up the cleat and threw it
all the way down the field
yeah that's your boy never good when you
don't know the
name until someone mentions the bad
thing they did
yeah when you're the meme and not the
player it's an issue all right so
it's tough out here buddy johnson for
the steelers that's the steelers pick
all the way an undersized linebacker for
the middle of the field downhill thumper
type
and you know just a lot of great things
about buddy johnson he was really
the leader of that texas a m i don't
even think defense but rather team 6-1
230 so compact linebacker
off the charts character over 500 snaps
on special teams if you have that much
special teams reps under your belt
you deserve to be drafted on day three
yeah yeah did the dirty work for that
long
yeah when you look at the steelers
though we haven't talked much about how
their draft has been going
what would you grade them as of now i
think it's a b-minus i'm not a fan of
running back in round one but i love
naji harris how can you not love
najihara
and he's gonna fit that steelers brand
of i'm gonna create my own yards i'm a
hard-nosed runner i'm gonna pass protect
catch the ball
make life a little bit easier on big ben
i know they took pat friar moves from
penn state
they need a big body in the middle of
the field for big ben that's what he and
he's a guy that'll give you a little
help as a move blocker those outside
runs you can get him going in motion
and have him on the move he's not going
to be here in line i'm going to take on
pass rushers keep the quarterback
upright that's not the name of his game
my question with the steelers has been
what's the planet corner
what's the plan on the offensive line
still some questions there and you look
at the best available
man if you need an offensive lineman
you're okay right now trey smith deante
brown
starters day one starter stone foresight
the uh
the empire state building size that left
tackle who is really good in pass pro
not much in the run game those big guys
they have a hard time getting leverage
and balance
you know you look at someone like daveon
nixon gap shooting interior defensive
lineman one year starter can give you a
little pass rush
juice i like quincy rochet from miami
he's a little bit of a situational
rusher because i don't think he's going
to hold up against the run right away
in the nfl but he's got good get off the
snap to win with the outside speed rush
last one for me here jamar johnson great
range
excellent range ball skills they picked
off justin fields twice in one game oh
wow okay
you know he's shown up against the best
of the best now you've talked a lot
about brevin jordan
and still up there still available yeah
interesting player right
he's an athletic tight end that didn't
test like a great athletic tight end he
tested like a
good one not a great one he's an
interesting player he's a move tight end
right he's what you look at what you
call an h you get them out in the slot
you like them on bubble screens you like
them running the seam
the red zone good speed you could even
use them as an h-back get them working
out of the backfield so
an athletic tight end that he just can't
block right now and it's been the name
of the game with this tight end class
you could either catch the ball or you
could block nobody could do both
even kyle pitts kyle pitts is a
game-changing tight end the blocking for
a 20 year old it's gonna get there
yeah even evan was like i don't think
he's gonna be blocking he's not gonna be
bought and if you're trapped in there
some people said about evan
that's a very good you get older yeah i
mean
cop it's gonna be a 20 year old on an
nfl field yeah some guys today
yesterday were drafted at 24 25 years
old he's gonna get bigger
stronger he's got a great attitude he'll
improve at it you're you're drafting him
to catch touchdown i know yeah
absolutely
all right do you have a player come for
him uh for kyle pitts yeah for brevan oh
but
since we're here i'd also love to hear
your kyle let's get all the tight end
comparisons
off kyle pitts to me uh it was darren
waller who was a superstar for the
raiders he's a no-brainer
i think when you look at brevin there
was times on film where i wanted him to
be jordan reed i thought he was more
irv smith the tight end out of alabama
that's been pretty good for the vikings
you know when you look at uh pat
friarmouth he reminds me of kevin boss
from the giants and here's brevin right
here this is what he can do he can get
off the line of scrimmage
and get down the field work the middle
of the field and he's got some juice
after the catch for a big body player
coaches will love that because if you
can get him in space he can run by
linebackers
he's traditionally bigger than defensive
backs that's what we call a mismatch
player you see him on the line of
scrimmage here
and he's getting after it as a blocker
there so he's probably laughing at me
saying you want to see something i can
block a little bit
it's gonna be a little tougher in the
nfl but he can get there so reverend
jordan the league is obsessed with these
kind of players we just saw johnny smith
get the bag and free agency from new
england
everybody loves these athletic tight
ends yeah absolutely i love
my thing with the titans if you were a
titan i'd consider drafting fairly high
in fantasy i know you're good i love the
ones that really function as a receiver
you know i was laughing that's the only
thing i'll do yeah you if you want to be
known at tight end you better be putting
up fantasy points otherwise everybody
doesn't watch your blocking film it's a
tough world out there for them
but i i think kyle pitch is gonna be one
of those guys that will get you those
points so
i'm excited and i think it looks like
the same for for him as well
right the rams have selected wide
receiver jacob harris
one of the more interesting players
throughout this draft process was not on
my initial list at
all when he was coming out of ucf and
the testing was
like eye opening that's the only reason
you turn on the film and watch him he's
six foot five
219 pounds runs a four four three forty
jumps out of the gym over a forty inch
vertical
a six five one three cone is like alien
status that's in the 98th percentile
that means
at that size he is as shifty as it gets
so this is a
famous words draft and stash player
middle field of the target we know they
like those athletic guys in the middle
of the field
once he's too fast for linebackers he's
too big for dbs
but is the polish there is he there's no
routes there right now he's not a route
runner
uh you want to just get him working in
practice and teach him the nuances of
being a pass catcher so for jacob harris
just a gigantic wide receiver that i
guarantee they'd get up to about 2 30
and move them to tight end
and i feel like the rams one of the
teams you have
that opportunity sure you absolutely
have that opportunity to make it onto
the field
yeah without a doubt i mean they got a
lot of weapons they know they have matt
stafford that is going to spread the
ball around something he's done a lot of
his career recently so when you look at
it for harris this is more of
man you're our type right you're just
bigger and faster than everyone else we
don't even care if there's not
you know jaw-dropping production there
we can roll with betting on you
packers selected an offensive tackle all
right royce newman
aaron's at home like they're trying
taylor
they're trying taylor yeah i mean what
do you think about royce's
the royce pick he's one of my favorite
picks of the day so far one of the most
athletic offensive linemen in the strap
that can play all five spots so for the
packers if you're trying to get aaron
rodgers back royce newman's a
a smart selection he might it's funny
how this works see my comp for him was
billy turner he already starts with the
packers yeah everybody has a type talent
totally
and they don't stray away from that no
they do not on the nfl that's for sure
so you know we got some recent picks
here
a lot of developmental talent here a lot
not a lot of guys that are going to come
in and play right away
that's okay that's kind of the name of
the game here when you look at
uh day three early day three late day
three of the draft and
yeah i'm excited here cause i know we
got the fantasy footballers coming in
and we're going to ask them about all
these skill guys that have just been
flying off the board i've been saying
this is too late for them this is too
late
so these guys they know this as much as
anybody these skill guys andy mike and
jason
they talk about it all year round
obviously we got a lot of great wide
receivers in this draft it's a
quarterback changing trap
let's bring them up let's get let's get
them in here i want to talk to these
guys and ask them what they've seen in
the first two days
guys what's going on oh yeah oh my
goodness it's uh
information overload the culmination of
months of speculation for fantasy
players
fear fear just permeating through
dynasty rosters
who's gonna mess up your fantasy team
but who's gonna help it it's it's been a
fun weekend
it really has guys and this is one of
those drafts where you know you get
a ton of first round quarterbacks and
that's going to be the conversation and
we'll get to those guys in a little bit
but i want to ask you you know last year
i think the big buzz was
clyde edwards a lair goes to a guy that
wasn't a consensus number one running
back coming into the draft maybe not
even top he wasn't in my top three i
think he was four or five
and then in fantasy the script really
flips real quick i mean he becomes this
round one maybe
early round two kind of player who's the
guy in this draft that might not have
been a consensus number one at his
position for
each of you but because of the landing
spot you're sitting there and going man
i'm starting to feel this one
yeah i i think uh you know seeing
michael carter go to the jets i'll start
with a little bit
i know you'll want to talk about naji
but uh
you know michael carter you look at
opportunity being king and fantasy
football and having
you know they have a great offensive
line that they're building right now and
i think that i'm i'm pretty optimistic
about his
year one impact on that team um
i think he's gonna come in right away
and and and show you something
that fantasy owners want to see and and
he was a very
you know we kind of faded away into the
background a little bit when it comes to
the draft community paying attention to
the big three guys
but opportunity is king and fantasy and
and he's one of the guys that i'm i'm
looking forward to seeing
yeah you know when when you talk about
dynasty there's guys like uh javonte
that i i think his landing spot is good
but not for this year
right if you're wanting someone that was
maybe a little lower on on people's
boards that i think could come in and
actually make an impact
to me it's trey sermon i trust kyle
shanahan i trust that run game
i'm sorry that you have raheem moster it
did not go well for andy's dynasty team
but trey sermons the guy that when i
watched the tape uh obviously there's
there was a lot to
love and a lot to hate because it kind
of came in a few games but
man when he had his games it was like
this
this dude could be special you pair him
up with the niners
that run scheme and my trust that i have
in just saying
yeah i'll go with the shanahan running
back uh he's he's the guy that jumped
the most for me
yeah and and i'm just gonna stay up
there at the top naji has been my
guy the entire draft process he was my
number one running back
uh coming into the draft and connor you
were talking about
clyde made the jump and we all kind of
fell victim to it of
of clyde's going to the best situation
that he can get to
while most of us have jonathan taylor as
our number one guy but
clyde's on the chiefs you know what does
that do well naji goes exactly where he
needed to go
to the pittsburgh steelers we aren't
real-life nfl players we don't
we're not debating the merits of
drafting a first-round running back
while the offensive line
is in absolute shambles i don't care
about that
i'm playing fantasy football and i want
to know that my running back
with a three-down skill set is gonna go
in and get all of the opportunity that
he deserves
mike tomlin has shown time and time and
time again
that he wants one dude out there just
absolutely crushing and taking souls on
the football field
and naji harris is that guy we're gonna
there's so few
day one there's so few fantasy options
at running back that can
give you three downs and that means so
much when it comes to plugging them into
your lineup
and trusting them every single week
because we saw a lot of other situations
now where
you know you brought up trey sherman as
raheem mostert a full-time guy james
robinson gives you 1400 yards
they say i don't care i don't care
anymore so it's going to be
uh it'll be fun to watch naji play in
pittsburgh yeah i love those pics guys i
mean when you start with michael carter
and the new york jets they just they
don't have a starting running back right
now he might have got drafted to be a
starter are you expecting much from the
michael perein or kevin coleman not much
there so
look at that wide zone running attack
with leflore that's just a no-brainer
that's a guy that definitely made
himself
a nice jump naji three down player i'm
with you there volume volume volume and
i
you know you never bet against kyle
shanahan's run game trey sermon was
built for that he's one injury away from
being on the radar
as a starter right away now on the flip
side the not so fun was there a player
that you came into this draft with that
you go
man this is a guy that i really like but
he's got to go to the right spot
and it kind of just fell short whether
he might just be buried early on it
might be a dynasty stash pick
or something else well i'll just throw
rashad bacon out there because
you might as well we talked so much
about the passing game in baltimore and
rashad bateman is such a dynamic player
and unfortunately for fantasy purposes
we've lived
the week to week low passing volume game
from lamar jackson and company it hurts
hollywood
it hurts mark anders from time to time
and here's rashad bateman coming in
to uh just a lower pass volume often so
i think
predicting which weeks he's going to
perform for your team
is going to be impossible that's been
one of the biggest challenges with that
offense
and so when you see uh that talent go to
a place where the opportunity might not
be consistent i think you kind of
you kind of you're a little sad you're a
little bit disappointed yeah and
and for me it's travis etienne a lot of
people's number one running back coming
in
and there were so many great landing
spots you know it's like will miami grab
a first round or even an early second
round running
atlanta and the jets and then it's oh
or or the or the jaguars who had a pro
bowl uh
rookie last year and then they signed
carlos hyde will they bring him in and
it's one of those unfortunate situations
where
if you want him for fantasy what's going
to end up happening
is you're going to need to draft him
early but he's not going to be good in
the beginning of the year now i expect
him to take over
and it's going to be his show by the
time that you know the
by the time the season ends like what we
saw last year with with cam acres what
we saw last year even with jonathan
taylor where it took him a while
but you have to struggle through the
first
half of the season and that that stinks
yeah yeah and i'm gonna throw out
javonte
williams it was rough this draft has not
been the best
if you loaded up on first round rookie
picks if you traded everything away and
saying i'm gonna rebuild in this draft
it did not go your way two of the big
three running backs are going
i mean etn could take over right he
should honestly take over
but melvin gordon is going to play even
if giovante
establishes dominance in that backfield
and becomes the primary running back
what does that look like 52 55
of the work because melvin gordon is not
going away at least
this year but i mean looking forward to
the future williams is going to be an
absolute monster with his
his three down skill set and his contact
balance of uh
uh very kareem hunt like just it's very
difficult to take him down
but for the immediate future where we
love these rookie running backs we love
getting hyped
we get that rookie fever just boiling
over our bodies
it's uh it's a little lukewarm this year
for those running backs you already have
one
although melvin gordon is contract
you're yeah unrestricted free agent so
dynasty outlook great for 2022
yes yeah i think the uh the etn quote
from urban kind of broke my heart a
little bit i'm like yes come on man
and it's also a little bit of bs let's
call it like we see it oh it is
talented to be a third down running back
and rb3 in that offense that's not
happening getting to the quarterbacks
you know you look at this like we said
legendary quarterback class
i think there's a lot of excitement
trevor lawrence and zach wilson starting
new eras for franchises that have
struggled
and they're really making a concerted
effort to build around those guys
quickly
trey lance i'm a believer that he will
be on the field much earlier than people
think this is a guy that needs reps not
more time
sitting out and then of course you have
the big trade up for justin fields and
we'll see when mack jones gets on the
field
how do you guys sort out this
quarterback situation you can make the
argument that
obviously all of them are extremely
talented but how do we project the
rookie impact from these guys
usually with a rookie quarterback you
want
mobility they're not going to throw
usually for
30 plus touchdowns and over 4 500 yards
so what you're looking for is the one
that can run for
600 700 800 plus yards and
you know to me that is clearly trey
lance
i don't expect garoppolo to be on this
team i know that they're saying
uh i i believe kyle shanahan just came
out and said it's gonna be very hard
for trey lance to establish himself as
the starter over garoppolo
wink wink yeah that's how i feel too
it's like okay well let's see if
garoppolo is on the team i think over
the next month or two
you're going to have some of these
situations develop will fields another
mobile quarterback be able to be the
starter day one that's kind of what you
need to figure out before your draft
comes in august
and that can't make it difficult from a
fantasy perspective to look at all of
the weapons on those teams you know we
talk about alan robinson never getting
the opportunity to play
with a uh high level hey let's call it
let's say uh decent
decent mediocre but what's hard
is if you do see transitions on both of
those teams if andy dalton happens to
start the year
for a game or two if it's jimmy
garoppolo for a few weeks
there's a level of predictability uh
there that is is difficult to see you
know with debo and ayuk and
look trey lance how can you come into a
better situation than what he's coming
into
viable weapons everywhere a quarterback
that's going to put him in a position to
kind of
you know exploit the things he's good at
today develop the things he needs to get
good at down in the field
or you know maybe that's part of it
maybe it's getting it to debo and i you
can
in short area and then using your legs
but uh from a predictability standpoint
you just want to know whether they're
out there on the field and we're gonna
have a lot of questions answered soon
yeah and i mean trey lance trey lance is
going to be
a a cheat code absolutely for fantasy
football i mean just due to scoring
you rush 10 yards you get a point you
throw for 25 you get a point
yeah just just do the math it's not it's
not that hard trey lance is gonna be
running all over
and the fact that in shanahan's system
he just has to like
just just throw it one or two yards
forward and then brandon nyuk
is going to take care of it for you and
then and then that running game gets
going
and then suddenly the play action and
george kittle is wide open in the middle
of the field somehow
so trey lance of of the rookies that
will make an immediate impact
assuming he starts week one i would go
with trey lance we know that trevor
lawrence feels like this
much safer option but trey lance is just
surrounded by talent and opportunity
yeah i truly think he could be the best
quarterback to come out of this draft
and i know that raises some eyebrows
with trevor lawrence and a ton of talent
but
trey lance is somebody that when you
watch the 2019 tape when he was 19 took
care of the football 28 touchdowns no
picks the running ability
the leadership the smarts he's going to
flourish there so now as we watch
day three unfold and i know it's been
flying i know there's a lot to keep up
with
but who are the day three guys that they
could have been picked or they're still
sitting on the board
that you you carry the flag for you'd
pound the table for right now
um yeah i mean we we we brought up
michael carter that's definitely a day
three pick that i think is
is the the clear clear home run to me
oh brevin jordan just went to the
houston texans andy
okay now that you are a brevin jordan
guy yeah absolutely
athletic tight end love him love the
opportunity there not sure who the
quarterback's gonna be yeah yeah but uh
you know you can bring up raimonde uh
stevenson to the patriots too where like
you know there's a lot of hype around
kenneth gainwell i don't know if
between the time we've come on with you
he's gone yet but he hadn't
you've seen some of these other running
backs bigger guys go off the board
stevenson somebody that's like okay
what's the opportunity going to be like
legarrette blunt i mean there's the cop
right but again yeah you're looking for
these
avenues you're looking for that
narrative where how does this player
on day three of the draft find his way
into a valuable role
i think i saw it tweeted you know that
you know the majority of these
these day three picks these are the guys
that are going to be out there on the
field but you got to find diamonds in
the rough and they're not the players
that have the draft capital to demand
opportunities
that's what's so valuable in fantasy is
you know day one day two
the investment is so high i mean we've
talked a lot on the show about kyle
pitts and what to expect out of rookie
tight ends because
they generally don't perform for fantasy
but this is the highest we've ever seen
them drafted
with such an opportunity to be out there
on the field i think stevenson's
interesting on day three yeah and i
honestly right now i mean we know just
once you hit that fourth round
the the chance of you hitting as a
fantasy player
the percentage just absolutely plummets
so for me right now
we already brought him up but it is
michael carter or bust uh
carter didn't prospect i wasn't as in
love with michael carter as the as draft
twitter was they were getting hot and
heavy
for michael carter i think maybe some of
the athletic testing
kind of eased those flames a little a
little bit where
if you're that size you you better be
lightning fast and so
the combination wasn't there uh i'm
still holding out hope for my man
michael p ryan over here not happening
sitting on my dynasty team
uh but i know that even even as a fourth
round pick
michael carter has an opportunity to
come in and be the day one started for
that team
yeah i have a feeling the floor has been
around shanahan too long you're gonna
see him just rotate back after back
you'll get a little p-ride you'll get a
little carter
uh on and on and on guys thank you so
much for joining us this has been a
blast
and we'll have we'll have to catch up
soon but thank you
absolutely thank you fun have a good one
they are just so much fun connor all
right
recent picks your guy rev jordan there
he goes
and you know it's tough to get really
excited about whatever's going on down
there with the texans right now
but at the end of the day taylor he can
come in and make an impact there because
they need pass catchers for the middle
of the field so
good to see brevin jordan come off the
board right we talked about his
athleticism now
the question we're going to always have
is who's going to be playing quarterback
there
we're going to see what happens with
what's going on with desean we're going
to see
obviously tyrod taylor's there they
drafted davis mills
guess what whoever's playing quarterback
needs a middle of the field athletic
tight end like this so for brevin jordan
not the worst landing spot i think
there's actually targets for him in this
offense and a lot of guys that are
drafted
this late at the skill spots that's not
always the case a nice hurdle there as
well so brevin jordan good
athlete and can get on the field in some
kind of role for them yeah
absolutely any guys that were just
drafted that also really stick out to
you
yeah i mean we're catching up here we
wrapped up round four went really quick
we had jamin sherwood go to the jets
more of a match-up player
things are flying real quick you know
and we're still kind of waiting on some
of these good receivers to come off the
board we talked about jacob harris
not really you know a ton here at the
skill spots royce newman is someone i
like for the packers i think he can play
right tackle he can play guard
he's started at both before tyree
gillepsky the raiders love those
safeties right now and they're getting
all the ones that can cover i think
they've had enough of patrick mahomes
just constantly throwing it on him so
i think the raiders did a good job with
their secondary here gillespie has nice
value
in that spot and when you look at
deontay smith more of a developmental
tackle
i still wonder what's going on with the
big boys at guard with trey smith and
deontay brown i
i know deontay brown he was somebody
that had a six game suspension he came
back from and really turned things
around really got his focus and got
right and played at a high level
with trey we talked about the blood
clots earlier so maybe it's a little bit
of medical concerns but
he's one of my favorite offensive
lineman film to watch so i'm excited to
see where these guys go because i will i
will say it
i think they could start from day one no
matter where they're drafted all right
now you know
i have a bit of a vested interest in the
falcons i see that they took taekwon
graham defensive tackle
tell me about him yeah i mean a player
that you know not a ton of upside when
you look at graham i'm looking up where
i have him stacked right now but hey
let me just say that is not what i was
hoping to hear
he did not make the top 250 but that's
okay he's got
long arms he's an interior defensive
lineman
a huge tester i just thought the film
was a little underwhelming i just
thought the productivity
wasn't necessarily there and you see the
highlights his best work is going to be
on those stunts and using those long
arms to climb over guards and get in the
backfield and make a play so
he tested a lot better than the film
showed up taylor and with that
you can get a player that and maybe just
the green light comes on at the next
level it didn't work out at the college
level so when you look at taequan graham
not surprised he gets drafted when
you're that big and that explosive
you're going to hear your name called
off the board but i just did not see it
on the film yeah and i mean really the
falcons are just doing our best to stack
their defense
yes take defense after defense for the
falcons they needed to
i think needed to is a bit of an
understatement but yeah
i appreciate it thanks teammate all
right um some of your favorite guys
still left
yeah kenny gainwell a little bit
perplexing to be honest with you and
this might be one of the cases where
they're holding the opt out against him
which i'm not personally a fan of i
think guys all of their personal reasons
why they didn't play this year
he's a former high school quarterback
that has one monster year at running
back there's not much tread on the tires
can play slot receiver great pass
catcher very shifty i thought he
reminded me a little bit of lashawn
mccoy to be honest with you with that
shake
so kenny gainwell somebody that can come
in and be your third down back from day
one wherever he gets his name called off
the board
there's been running backs that do not
have as much talent as him
uh already heard their name called so
very confused by that one
there's obviously every year there's
some conversation about do
people drops running backs too high i'm
just curious your thoughts on
running backs drafting them where they
belong shelf life all those things yeah
so it's a catch-22 right you look at it
this draft i thought had three really
really good ones
with naji harris travis etienne and
javonte williams
problem is word gets out those are the
three really good ones you have the
first two guys go in the first round
you have javonte williams the broncos
come up and get him at the top of round
two
so it's a position you traditionally
don't want to use premium assets on
but the problem is a lot of the top
level guys were this is not a deep class
this was not the class that
hey there's my guy in round five that's
gonna start for us i think you know you
go back to the jets i think michael
carter is one of those guys that reminds
me of devonta freeman that
he could be something for you there i
think randre stevenson goes to the
patriots reminds me of legarrette blount
he could be a rotational guy there trey
sermon the niners wait every year to
take a running back later on once they
get outside of round two
they open up that running book uh
running back tab on their binder and say
all right which one are we taking so
trey sermon he just needs to stay
healthy he's got talent as a starter but
he just can't stay healthy
so when you look at it at chuba hubbard
to carolina really nice backup for
christian mccaffrey i think you want to
wait on running backs you always want to
have one waiting in the wings in case
your guy leaves him for agency or gets
hurt
you don't want to be out in free agency
chasing the big dollar running backs it
never works out
yeah it's also nice to have you know the
ability to have a bit of a one-two punch
yeah we've seen that work so well i
always really
just think of chubb and kareem hunt that
worked so
well for the browns and i'm like um can
every team do this can falcons do this
speaking of it kenny gamewell just went
off the board to adam lefko's eagles
oh look at that yeah absolutely i know
i'm not doing great today
i haven't even tried if this is working
i guess i'm just gonna press the buttons
and see
but this would be an a plus pick for me
so i think when you look at gainwell
uh once again it's funny i compare him
to lashawn mccoy two minutes ago where
does he go the eagles this is just
i'm telling you nfl teams are a type and
i know it's a different regime there but
still when they put on that eagles green
it's gonna feel a little bit of the same
i'm just gonna i don't know i don't want
to leave anyone hung out to try
it's okay we're not doing great today
i'm just having fun uh when you look at
it
kenny gained well played in the slot
played in the backfield he likes to chip
in pass protection what i mean by that
is you don't necessarily want him
staying in and looking where's the
blitzer coming
you want my offensive linemaker can use
a little help on that outside shoulder
i'll throw my body around and the one
that jumped out to me he put micah
parsons on the ground and he's a smaller
guy
he put micah parsons on the ground and
michael barton is not a smart guy no i
didn't do
that michael wasn't looking so i want to
be fair and give my disclaimer if mike
if micah hears this
okay of those running backs though who
will have the best season
ooh great question and you heard the guy
say with the fantasy footballers naji
harris is poised for the volume
and that's the name of the game at
running back who's getting the targets
who's getting the carries
who's getting the reps he's a three-down
player that's why he went in the top 25
in a position that's not drafted in the
top 25 traditionally anymore
all right absolutely you know twitter uh
still going crazy right now
everybody's still weighing in um on day
three
of the draft everybody very excited uh
talking a lot about
jalen twyman and all of these things so
still very fun on the internet connor
always having a good time online
i used to have a landlord who thought he
could fix everything here we go again
he could not
when you need to throw in the towel on
renting rocket cam
you got any tape
[Music]
all right we welcome in future hall of
famer demarcus we are here to talk
some defense very excited so many super
talented guys
have gone in this draft so far now
demarcus before we get into you know the
nitty-gritty of each guy i'm so
curious how has defense changed you know
from your time
in the league until now specifically in
the front seven
you know what a lot of the guys when i
played they were huge you had the chris
canty the marcus spears just to name a
few of those guys
getting drafted right but now the guys
are getting smaller they're getting
smaller they're getting faster
and i'm starting to see a lot of the
younger guys getting drafted earlier
early in the in the first round because
usually it's a lot of the offensive guys
like
this draft but usually defense win
championships and a lot of those guys
get drafted early when i played
but it's really changed and uh and you
see how the game has changed too
the scoreboard uh gets up pretty high
now
compared to when i played yeah
absolutely because on the flip
side of that i mean how have you seen
offenses change because the defenses
have had to adapt to this very
fast-paced game yeah look at look at
when
i played larry allen flozael adams
jonathan ogden
walter jones you had so many of those
guys right they were short
but big strong guys right but now you
got these big huge tall basketball guys
that are coming in like the older
orlando paces that are really fast or
quick
uh really really agile and uh it's
really changing now to a passing game
instead of a run game
yeah for sure now so many talented guys
uh
taken so far some notable front seven
guys for sure
tell me about iowa's chauncey golson who
is now a dallas cowboy
uh what do you like about his game i
really like his get off right
one thing that you always look at from a
defensive hand standpoint defensive
tackle
standpoint is how aggressive they get
off the football right
and look at him right here you can see
that he was doing a boot
reaction type read and that's what you
want from a defensive end somebody
that's smart and here you can see him
playing in the interior
getting off getting great pocket
presents and then pushing back and
almost knocking the ball out look at him
here on the outside
getting out the ball you see him getting
off good swim move getting a good
quarterback sad
i mean you had this guy in three
different spots and he's still here with
the tight end so he gets a chip with the
tight end
and then all of a sudden now look at
this the defensive ends don't catch
the football so he's a very very
athletic kid and that's what the dallas
cowboys been wanting going from a 4-3
3-4 type defense and now they got a more
versatile guy like when i played
they can drop back rush to pass it but
also stop the run
and i mean while we're on the subject of
the dallas cowboys this defense such an
upgrade i mean micah parsons what should
we expect
from this dallas cowboys i mean it's
very exciting
it's crazy because they're going to a
4-3 and you got to have monster
linebackers especially with
sean lee retiring you're bringing in the
michael parson right that's going to be
to fill his spot
and then you got jalen smith with
leighton banderas
and this guy right here they say that he
can't go sideline the sideline we see it
right here on tape the tape does not lie
he can really get to the football and
that's what you want from an outside
linebacker
in a 3-4 type defense that can you now
read and react
play special teams wherever you put them
at he's going to be
effective that's why the dallas cowboys
pick this guy because when you're
playing a 4-3
you got to have somebody that likes to
get
to the football and you can see that
this penn state kid right here is going
to be the guy
that they're really looking for that's
going to fill the shoes of sean lee
and get that defense going again of
course any uh other edge rushers in this
draft that you're a big fan of
you know what the third round draft
picks the third fourth round draft pick
guys let's say
a jordan smith right from uab younger
guy
rashad weaver you know you got him
coming in there
uh carlson i think basham i don't want
to really butcher their names but
these are the guys that we're really
looking for because when i got drafted
you know i was projected a six round
draft pick i moved up to the first round
but i was hungry i know that all of
these guys are going to be hungry
they're younger guys coming in
and they're going to be impact players
for the team that they're playing for
all right i'm putting on the spot here
but if you had to make a pick for
defensive rookie of the year
oh man
it's a rookie of the year i gotta go
with the corner
right i would say um patrick certain uh
with the denver broncos i think he's
gonna be um the rookie of the year
defensive rookie of the year because
he's a guy that's gonna come in and make
uh impact right now for the denver
broncos you got
von miller coming back being able to
create a lot of pressure
but in a guy i mean he was playing
against you know
you know honorable wide receivers over
and over
every week practicing it against those
guys and you can see i'm here you can
get up and get that football
and that's what you want from a
cornerback and he's going to make those
immediate plays
big interceptions getting turnovers but
then being able to come up in the run
game
and hit guys like this that's when you
make a statement on the outside
a guy that can chase sideline the
sideline make those big plays
and get the job done so i can't wait to
see this guy
the defensive rookie of the year all
right you heard it here first i i
believe the last time you know a corner
one that orders marshawn lattimore and
they are
going into very similar situations so i
can i can see him
winning that one uh anybody in this
year's draft that reminds you a bit of
yourself
um i would say the jordan smith kid from
uab uh he's a really tall lanky kid
um no one really looked at him but he
played a lot of talent i keep saying the
jordan smith kid
because he's right under the radar right
under everybody's nose and he's going to
come in and make a big impact
and he's one of those players that no
matter where you put him
he's going to be able to get to the
quarterback make big plays and that's
what you want from a defensive guy
when he first comes out what there he
he's in the inside here making big plays
stopping the run
and this is what you're going to want
from a defensive end when he first comes
out just make plays
and do what you need to do he's here at
the top and look look how fast he gets
off the ball right i mean he's lingering
a little bit here
but he's not stopping um making plays oh
whoa wait a minute i didn't know there
was an interception but
uh great play there and the kid's going
to make some good plays
what do you think every incoming
linebacker
needs to know about succeeding in the
nfl
um i think the playbook is going to be
the most important thing that they're
going to have to learn
they have athleticism but you have to
learn the game
the x's and o's they move now they got
personality so you're going to have to
figure out
which guys you're going to be able to go
against
where you fit in the defense but also
react before the play even happens
so i think playing that playbook getting
in that playbook and learning the
playbook
is going to be the most um the biggest
thing they need to learn
uh coming out into the nfl
all right well great advice and thank
you so much for joining us
here to marcus truly appreciate your
time
hey thank you guys for inviting me on
have a great one
[Music]
all right more merch don't forget send
in your videos leave us some comments
more you do the more you might have some
of this merch right at your door
and i don't know about you all but i
love free stuff so make sure
that you keep on sending them in
all right don't you i mean some great
stuff doesn't matter
all right we have a another guest on the
way
the one and only deandre swift
joins us now please welcome in the lions
running back deandre it is
so good to see you um and as a dog
i think that you're having a really
really good past couple days huh
most definitely getting to see all the
guys get drafted for their dreams been a
good couple days
yeah for sure so many of your friends
and former teammates drafted
uj actually set a school record of six
players drafted in the first three
rounds
of the nfl draft so what does that say
about the state
of uga football everything
um speaks volumes of kirby smart and the
staff at georgia they prepare these
young men
um to get ready for the nfl and now
we're not done we got a couple more
getting off the board today hopefully
god willing so we're not done yet
all right let's talk about you know some
of those guys eric stokes goes 29th
overall had four interceptions last
season
only about three touchdowns um in
coverage in his career in athens
tell green bay fans exactly what kind of
corner
they are getting amazing guy on and off
the field somebody that's going to work
stokes is one of the people i saw
firsthand when he came in
um the way he just polished his his
craft and
got better each and every day went to
work and just was a pro before he even
got there so
i'm so happy for him and to see his
success
all right we've also got of course aziz
ojulari taken at 50 and quite the steal
i mean how shocked were you to still see
him
available yeah i definitely thought he
was off the board
uh day one but these guys gonna be high
energy every day in practice technician
wants to be the best person out there on
the field
all right monty rice exciting player
tell me about him
monty a guy that made me better i love
competing with him um high energy high
motor type of guy
great leader um tiger's got a good one
all right so tell me some guys you know
that we will be watching
and a uga uniform this upcoming season
that we're going to be talking about
next season at this time you know i
gotta start with the running backs
as amir white you know guys james cook
they they next up them two right there
man i can't wait to see what they do
this uh this year especially under dale
mcgee one of the best running back
coaches out there in the country
i'm excited for them too all right now
deandre i did have a fellow running back
mark ingram on the show earlier i asked
him this question
i'm sure you can imagine his answer what
school
is rbu
not the school that he probably named uh
say
it's georgia i gotta go with georgia
okay please give me the rebuttal because
so you know when mark said that he chose
alabama i said well what if somebody
says something like
uga which i think clearly has an
argument
tell me what you would say to mark
i mean alabama is one of the teams that
i would definitely
put in second that'll put a second well
but not either
they got a good program good running
backs all around the country but i think
georgia uh with the talent that they put
out the running position running back
position each year
it's second to none yeah i mean i
i'm conflicted so i'm also being from
georgia i'm kind of like okay who am i
gonna pick but
i understand both arguments i must say i
totally understand both arguments
okay tell me about you what have you
been working on this off season
oh man just getting in the best shape
possible um
to get ready for whatever road that the
lion see fit for me working on
full body strength my conditioning um
just things like that just working each
and every
day getting a new playbook down got a
new staff so
just getting everything out the queen
all right now deandre i'm not sure if
you remember this but i met you at a
bowling event and i came up to you i
don't even think i said my name all i
said to you was hey deandre i need to
let you know
you are my fantasy team last year and
you got me some really clutch touchdowns
so so i again uh would
i again would like to uh thank you for
that um and please
let the fans know what they should
expect from the lions this season
energy um us having fun out there
definitely i'm trying to
do better than we did last year didn't
win as many games as i hoped
so definitely just getting back on track
um excited to meet the new guys get in
with the new coaches and
start building this thing all right
absolutely well deandre thank you so
much for your time and congrats on the
success that uga
is having um in this year's draft thank
you so much thank you for having me
yes bye have a good one
all right we've gotten some recent picks
for you connor
what's sticking out yeah we absolutely
do i like tony fields of the browns that
was one that stood out to me with value
120th player on my board a grad transfer
from arizona to west virginia
undersized linebacker just with great
instincts and a four-year starter in
college football you don't get a lot of
guys like that not a lot of guys start
all four years in college football but
he's a pretty twitchy athlete he could
blitz
blitz cover and stops to run sideline to
sideline and shoot gaps and read his
keys so
tony fields he's not going to be the
biggest fastest kind of guy but i just
thought he did everything the right way
and really sees everything in front
of him pre-snap that's really going to
help get him on the field
they'll also have him a special team so
the browns they've added really good
uh undersized different athletic
linebackers so
and this is just absolutely bizarre and
leave it to
the jets that stick michael carter again
first running back
db it took two michael carter's on the
same day
so it's kind of like i think when you
order something and it's loading and
they tell you not to refresh the page i
think the jets refreshed the page and
double sent michael carter and they're
like well there are two
their card got charged twice yeah
exactly this feels like to me now
michael carter
the jets have a huge uh hole at slot
corner taylor so that's what they're
thinking here he
most of his snaps at duke was playing
the slot he played a little safety play
a little outside corner
was not in my top 250 you know really
didn't jump out i thought he was going
to be a priority free agent
obviously robert sala knew he can get a
slot corner late
that can come in and compete with
javelin guidry so i think when you look
at it here
uh michael carter has some pretty good
film for what he is
you know a slot corner with pretty good
feet good ball skills
but you know not a ton of size not
overly twitchy
and i just think when you look at this
this is very very early so
i hopefully they did accidentally send
michael carter in twice but the jets
needed help at corner so i think this
won't be the last time we hear them take
a corner today yeah
we've talked some about you know the job
that the bears are doing
and this year's draft i they just picked
up i believe an offensive tackle
uh what are your thoughts on that pick
yeah i mean they're flying in right now
so we have a lot coming in
let's catch up on on the last couple
here i mean for an ot
right now with justin fields you do what
you can and make sure he
can be successful and they take a big
body guy and larry borham who's very
interesting at pick
151 which is that's the right value for
him he's sitting at 166 for me
um you know i had had him in the fifth
round six five three twenty two
pretty good arm length i think he's
gonna play guard but former basketball
player
he has experience playing tackle and
guard he was really the muller that
paved the way for larry roundtree to run
behind him
okay nice 49ers another 0-0 line man
while we're on the subject jalen moore
yeah probably one of the better picks of
today honestly quietly i think when you
look at jalen moore i know he was a
favorite of coaches
i had him at 1 34. so this is a little
late for him i think
they're getting somebody that can play
tackle play guard really strong taylor
just somebody in a phone booth can
really drive guys backward and that's
why you like that transition to guard
especially in this scheme
they're gonna need him to move a little
bit so he was a tight end recruit
originally played defensive end
to begin his college football career
then was a three-year starter at left
tackle that's a crazy transit
transition for jalen moore mauler
springy lower half they need that they
run a wide zone rushing attack you got
to be able to move from your lower half
a little out of control lunges a little
bit he's not going to start right away
that's okay
and my last line you love this and every
player hustles his ass off that's the
last thing i wrote i like jaylen moore a
lot i know coaches love jaylen moore
yeah i mean that's you need a guy who is
going to do what needs to be done
no matter what and he seems to be that
guy you know we've talked about
you know just the development you know
we see the guys that aren't going to
play right away
what do you think are some of the
hurdles um of that development
it's a great question i think the speed
of the game i think that's number one
and then the second thing could be reps
right you're the man at college then you
go to the league and it's like man if
i'm third string i'm not getting the
reps
that i need to get better and that's a
thing that's been tough with the nfl in
the new cba agreement there's no more
two days
there's less practice time there's less
face-to-face time coaches with the
players
you almost have to be a self-motivator
today's nfl that's that's a hard thing
for a lot of people in this world so
you don't have necessarily the time with
the staff that they need so i think when
you look at it
that's why you're betting on guys like
this these these are team captains these
are high
effort guys high hustle guys think of a
jalen moore think of a tony fields
you know these are the players that they
can lead their own way and they just do
all the work and work really hard to get
to that starter level or provide
reliable backup skills where it's
hey i don't know if i'm playing today
i'm not in the starting lineup but one
injury away i could be on the field how
do i mentally prepare those are the
things that you're looking for in these
kind of prospects
you know i also love seeing the kicker
get some love you gotta love the kicker
get some love yeah we ca shout out to
evan mcpherson right
yeah so it was between evan mcpherson
this how you know i'm a real draft nerd
it was between
and jose boragalus uh you know i thought
boragalus had the bigger leg and he was
the grozo award winner i think with
mcpherson you might get a little bit
more steady
is what you're thinking there so fifth
round kicker i know there's prop bets
out there you could pick when the first
kicker goes and that's okay insane world
i would have said a little later than
this so good for evan mcpherson get a
little more of those guaranteed money to
uh with the big leg
yeah i mean you know kickers end up
being like the butt of a lot of jokes
but they will literally win you or
losing oh
yeah they'll lose you a lot of games
yeah everybody laughs on draft day like
me and taylor right now and then you're
not laughing when they're out of the
playoffs because of a mis-kick
30 yards 35 yards yeah absolutely
anybody you are
surprised that they are still available
it just goes back to these guards and i
feel bad
for them actually i really do i think
with trey smith i think it's just about
bad injury luck and that
could be bad health lucky guy came back
from blood clot injury and played at a
significantly high level tested really
well
very perplexed by jamar johnson i
thought he'd be the biggest riser in
this class he's somebody i was
late on i found him the beginning of
april and said oh boy i feel like an
idiot for not having him on my radar and
found him at 59. that's a
late second round player and he's still
sitting there on the board he might be
scared of being a one-year starter
patrick johnson is way too good to be
sitting there right now he knows how to
do one thing taylor let's get after the
quarterback that's a
that's a money skill in the nfl those
are the guys that get paid so at the
quarterbacks get paid and the guys that
hurt the quarterbacks get paid patrick
johnson can do that i like him a lot
and then you get into you know stone
foresight this one that doesn't make
sense to me i remember my last
conversation with an
offensive line coach was you know hey
who's the who's the guy that is
projected on day three that you think
can start right away and be reliable to
keep his quarterback upright not a
perfect player but reliable
and some forsythe was the guy so it's a
little weird that he's still on the
board here i know he's not a great run
blocker but he could pass protect and
that that makes you a lot of money at
the next level on the offensive line i
think we'll see him come off the board
pretty soon
connor why do you think uh sean wade is
still available bumpy year
taylor bumpy here and for sean wade
really good slot guy in 2019
expectations through the roof when you
play at a program like ohio state where
it's first round corner after first
round corner and day two safeties and
day one defensive line ohio state just
puts out starters at defense in the nfl
over and over again
sean wade fell into the trap of wait in
2019 you had to play in the slot because
we had two guys
and you were really good okay cool
you're in the first round of every mock
draft that comes out the maniacs that do
2022 mock draft the day after today
right
and everybody goes oh sean wade there's
sean wade that the spotlight's on you he
moves to the outside
didn't work for him taylor gave up a lot
of touchdowns gave up a lot of catches
i just didn't see the ball in the air i
thought the speed was there
the size is fine it's adequate he it
just
the mental ability of knowing i got to
get my head turned around right now
check on the quarterback he just
couldn't find the football
he have a lot of big plays teams are
afraid of that now what i'll say for
sean wade is
if your film was great in the slot in
2019 all these teams are running base
nickel
defense three corners on the field gold
played the slot in the nfl the jets just
took michael carter from duke to play
the slot sean wade's a better player
than him i don't care how bad his
2020 was on the outside i hope for a
bounce back for sean wade because i
think it's one of those things where
we got i'm guilty of it we got too high
on the player he disappointed
and now it's overreaction time
is there one player that sticks out to
you that there was
too big of an overreaction it's probably
sean wade
right i think we're sitting here
watching him fall a little bit
it's that's a great question as you look
at it you know who's the guy that you
said oh man
now he can't take him because of this it
might be deante brown because i
he like i said he had that six game
suspension and i
you know then he came back and played
and played at a high level and the work
ethic was there
and you have somebody like josh ball who
went to the cowboys earlier today
who has significant off the field
baggage that i won't even begin to get
into i mean
you could google things he was proven
guilty for
so if there's character questions well
how does this guy go first
but i guess my answer is the dallas
cowboys if you want me to be
quite honest with you they take
character risk that's what they do
and you know we keep watching in this
board a player that i love just went to
the minnesota vikings in amir smith
marcet from iowa
a burner at wide receiver a player that
knows how to win down the field maybe
the opportunity wasn't always there for
the hawkeyes you reminded me of paul
richardson a player that has won
vertically down the field in the nfl
maybe an undersized guy
a little skinny that's okay he knows how
to track the ball so
amir smith marcette the vikings are good
at this
finding day three day two wide receivers
you look at a guy named stefan diggs
that came out of there oh yeah pretty
solid pretty solid they probably missed
him a little bit but you know they got
justin jefferson in round one
superstar that's how you're replacing
stefan diggs adam thielen that
one of the most hidden gems of any draft
because he wasn't drafted or signed as a
priority free agent davion nixon finally
comes off the board and the panthers you
know they need a gap shooter like this
somebody on the interior
play next to brian burns you know brian
burns can rush the outside
who's going to rush the inside davion
nixon is the guy it's it's third and 11.
i'm going to get them on the field i'm
going to say you've got one job right
now that's pin your ears back and go get
after the quarterback don't need you to
contain gaps you're not expecting the
run
gets washed out a little bit against the
run he's really a one year starter with
good production good pass rush
production
those kind of guys when they go at this
point in the draft they might surprise
you in training camp because how quick
they are
we'll find a role for them and that's
third downs passing downs third and
longs
and what's your outlook right now on the
panthers defense
you know what they're going in the right
direction and it started last year you
go up and get a big time corner this
year you didn't even have to move you
got your big time corner you got the big
guy in the middle and derek brown
i love brian burns i think he's one of
the most most impressive young edge
rushers in the entire nfl
jeremy chin maybe the best swiss army
knife in the nfl right now
under phil snow who you know typically
follows matt rule everywhere
this is this is the direction they
needed to go in they need to get faster
they need to get more physical
they need to make that middle more stout
because they got gashed in the run game
two years ago it was embarrassing matt
real got there and said
i can't allow this to happen it got a
little better last year and needs to go
in the right direction so
you look at the panthers defense is
going in the right direction it all
comes down to one thing though taylor
the man with the keys of the car our
quarterback has got to stop turning the
football over you got skill players
you got the right coaches you got some
ballers on defense that can make things
happen
sam darnold does not have to be a hero
he does not have to be a gunslinger he
just needs to go out there
make the throws he needs to not do
anything stupid take care of the
football and this panthers team can have
a big-time turnaround in year two under
matt rule
now i will say this i champion robbie
anderson
wow okay the sun god's my god just so
you know that i mean
he is so good i think sometimes people
see his size you're like uh whatever but
he is fast he will beat you you can sing
it downfield he'll catch it
that's another person who got me some
really good touchdown in the flex
position
absolutely and sam he is you know with
his old teammate
i think that there could be a really
good connection there for the panthers
there absolutely can and you look at
robbie's role in this offense they just
want him to win down the field and
that's what he's he's a lead at it i
mean if you look at the numbers robbie
anderson is an elite downfield target on
those vertical throws when the ball is
there whether it was teddy playing
whether it was sam two years ago sam
missed him a lot so if sam can clean
that up this year
that offense is going to be clicking
robbie's a great story i mean undrafted
free agent
he really figured it out with matt rule
at temple and when he had free agency
and said i'm going to go back to the guy
that's helped me in my career and get me
right
free agent year contract you're still
young not even close to 30.
i think robbie's in for a big year now
while we're on the subject of
quarterbacks and you know what's
surrounding them i do want to talk a
little bit
um just kind of about jared goff a
little bit more now that he's in detroit
and we just saw
deandre swift we know the lions are
fairly run heavy you know they have
deandre jamal williams carrion johnson
they will provide golf some relief but
do you think it's fair to say
you know a lot of his success is about
their success
absolutely it's completely fair you look
at him with the rams yeah gotha has
become a little bit of a punching bag
and
that's a little unfair for a player
that's had some big time games but
he's not going to give you a lot out of
structure it's got to be right he's got
to be healthy that was the problem as
well
it's got to be right you got to keep him
clean you need some talk he can make
every single throw he's a pocket passer
he's one of the best bucket throwers in
the nfl
but you know a lot of guys that's that's
kind of the book on mac jones right when
i'm an upright pocket passer and
everything's clean i can drop it in the
bucket wherever i need to
when things break down it gets ugly so
the lion sat there and said well let's
go get somebody up front that can really
protect him and pen a sew and we know we
got a good left tackle
we know we have a good interior
offensive line penny sew is going to
keep jared goff clean
yeah i think that's going to be a really
nice story line uh to watch throughout
this season
uh one thing conor byers talked about is
we like free stuff and if you
like free stuff there is so much
opportunity for
some free stuff you can get some of this
merch all you gotta do is drop a video
in the comments
drop some comments in the comments do
any of this go
to the nfl draft community on the br app
and leave it there and you might get
some all right some br
app comments how are the packers
simultaneously a super bowl contender
and a dumpster fire that's a there's a
duality
the realest comment of the week right
there i mean real talk that is spotlight
and you know what the somebody's putting
out the fire whether it's aaron rodgers
going out the door or goody getting
fired
it's going to be put out real quick
that's a real talk right there we've
gotta grab me a red bull we actually
need to
probably grab connor one two uh say it's
gonna be a long day
shocked that you are still up not just
that you're up there that your mind is
still working at such a high level
um we have this one connor where did you
get that sweatshirt
oh man well you know our woody sarah
shout out to woody he's the goat
she's the goat so that's where all the
secrets lie she knows how to get us
right taylor yeah
i'm feeling it you know that's an adam
lefko special to sweaters but when he
got out the door i was like hey
yeah you look very cool first thing i
said to connor when i saw him was i
really really like
your sweater so shout out to the sweater
all right and shout out to
our next guest okay coming in now we
have atlanta falcons beat rider for the
ajc orlando ledbetter
now i'm a falcons fan so i care deeply
about these next 10 minutes or so
so happy to have you joining us orlando
i love the bow tie we are
styling i uh obviously first want to
begin with
kyle pitts i have heard so many people
say they think he was the best player
in the whole draft what makes him so
special
yes he's a mismatch uh taylor just a big
kid
six six 240 could run really fast runs
like a
a wide receiver so a linebacker can't
cover him and then the cornerback is too
big
it's too little for him so uh you can
flex him out
he's got the he runs like a a wide out
uh he gets uh you know he could catch
the ball make some moves he's a good
weapon to be
added to the falcons offense
now one thing i'd say about the falcons
fan base
is very rarely does everybody seem to
agree and i think in some ways that was
the case this year there was a
contingent of falcons fans
that wanted the falcons to trade away
the fourth pick right and maybe
stack them on defense there was also a
contingent of falcons fans that said hey
maybe we should get a quarterback at the
fourth pick maybe we don't need matt
ryan anymore
i feel like kyle pitts probably was the
best option
but what do you think about the decision
the falcons made to keep for
and take a weapon for matt ryan
yeah it made sense uh you know certainly
uh i
thought that the the offensive tackle
would be under consideration
given that matt ryan's been sacked 133
times
over the last three years and that their
russian attack
has been ranked 27th 30th and 27th so
you know they got to get better up front
you know the fact that matt
ryan's got a new weapon doesn't really
matter much if he's laying on
the ground 40 times again next year so
but they have a plan for their line
uh they went out and got alignment in
the third round jalen mayfield from
michigan
and then took one again today drew
darmon from stanford
so um you know it made sense that they
had but
i wanted to know the plan for the line i
thought penny seoul would be
a better pick at four but he ended up
going seven to detroit
uh they got the weapon for matt they
might be bringing in a weapon while they
might be losing one here too
in this offseason so uh might be a uh
some net gain
for the falcons in the offensive weapon
department
all right let's talk a bit more about
jalen mayfield you know i'm protecting
the
qb we took him in the third round what
will he bring to the team
yeah jalen's a big kid taylor he's uh
six
five three twenty ish uh they're gonna
probably move him to guard
they really lack his raw power and his
ability to
to get after it in the run game he
played some tackle at michigan
uh you know had some good uh games
against uh
uh chase young at ohio state but uh
his future in the nfl and he has a high
ceiling
inside that guard because he can get
after it and match people and has
power i was um he was described to me as
a player with
uh some technical flaws but very
powerful and raw in the run game so that
should help the falcons out
as they have to play some pretty tough
defensive fronts in the nfc south
at tampa bay and new orleans so a big
kid like
jaylen mayfield should be able to help
them in the long run
yeah nfc south is no joke uh we all know
that atlanta
needed some safety help and that's where
ucf's richie grant comes in
falcons took him at 40. seems to me
he'll step
right into the starting lineup uh can he
be
one of the answers to the defensive
problems
yeah no question about it uh richie's a
guy
that looks you know runs around he's a
running hit guy
and he has showed up at the ball 291
times down at ucf
uh also a lot of uh passive defenses
and a lot of interceptions like 10
interceptions 17 past defense
so that's the type of guy you can sit
back in the uh
the free safety and let him you know
learn how to run a defense
and then uh he likes to hit so he can
come up and play near the line which is
kind of rare for free safety but
uh yeah interested to see how quickly he
can get adjusted to the nfl and how fast
they can get him on the field because
they let all four of their
top safeties go over the off-season
and a question that i'm sure is on the
minds of minnie
uh which matt ryan will we see this
season
well if you get the matt ryan who's
protected
and has his interior of the pocket firm
uh you that's playoff matt ryan they go
to the playoffs when he when
when you protect matt ryan when you
don't protect matt ryan he's running for
his life
you got the 18 and 30 met ryan that
we've had over the last three years so
uh if they could fix his offensive line
uh you know they
they give him time to throw and he can
you know read the defenses and
step into his throws that are deeper
down the field
um they go to playoffs he's gonna need a
running game to go with that
but um the falcons and matt ryan
uh you know matt ryan hasn't been the
problem here it's been the his
supporting cast
has gotten weaker around him and uh you
know so
goes the cast you know so goes the team
so
uh you know they need to sprinkle in a
little defense over there too
to help out but yeah matt ryan uh
matt ryan is not the problem here in
atlantis you know they got to fix the
stuff around
yeah just sprinkling a little bit of
defense for some help um
new arthur smith system help him or hurt
him
uh it helps it helps we've seen uh ryan
tannehill thrive in that system after
not
you know playing so well uh in miami and
getting ran out of town there so they
revived his career
in this system a lot of tight ends a lot
of double tight ends a lot of power
uh play action uh passing off of that
run game
uh only problem is that uh art smith
didn't get to bring derek henry with him
now you know this might be a bit of an
unpopular opinion but i always say
when you look at matt ryan's numbers i
do not think they are that far off from
you know those that we name these
elite qb's i think matt gets kind of a
lot of negativity that isn't always
fully deserved so many of these
issues that have existed with the
falcons aren't necessarily his
fault would you say he probably deserves
a bit more love and a bit more hype
um that he usually gets um
you know he was on path for that he was
getting a lot of love
uh you know at 16 when uh he won the mvp
and nearly won the super bowl but for
some shaky play calling shaky plays and
everything else so
so ever since then losing on the grand
stage and then following that up by
getting back to the playoffs and losing
to the eagles
you know they have three losing seasons
so if you're not winning
uh you lose that cashier you know but
back then
it was considered top five quarterback
uh in the league right now i don't think
uh
you know the public really considers him
a top ten quarterback to the point where
you know folks were thinking that the
team was ready to move on and look to a
new quarterback this year
so he's got a late in his career he'll
turn 36
in may and uh you know late in his
career he has a chance to
you know he's got a couple years left
here and he'll have a chance to
reestablish himself
as one of the elite quarterbacks in the
league
all right one of obviously the fan
favorite falcons is julio jones trade
rumors
continue to circulate where does that
stand at the moment
and is anything progressing with that
yeah the um you know uh julio is it a
bad situation with the falcons in his
contract he will be traded
uh it's just a matter of uh will they do
it post june 1
or before june 1 with the post june
designation
uh i don't know teams that'll be
interested
but uh the falcons only have 900 000
under the cap they need 12 million to
sign their rookies
and they could save 16 million by moving
julio's contract
so uh terry fontenot um told us on
wednesday
that the situation was fluid and so
whenever they started talking about
fluid situations that usually ends up in
a transaction
so um uh we we haven't been able to
effort julio for his comment
uh on the situation but we understand
that he's aware
uh that he'll be on the move here very
soon
all right well orlando thank you so much
for joining before i let you go
do the falcons make the playoffs yes or
no
no
stone cold stone cold oh my goodness
that hurt my heart orlando
oh i'm saying yes but as i've said
multiple times i say yes every year but
i'm gonna keep the hope alive all right
yeah keep loving keep going yes
thank you so much for joining us orlando
i appreciate your time welcome thank you
for having me and keeping up the great
work
thanks so much i just became orlando's
number one fan yeah he said no
he did all of that and he's crushed
and then he goes nah nah make it sorry
taylor crush the hearts of
all these falcons fans that we're seeing
on this twitter board
including me that really hurt me
my heart like my heart dropped a little
bit so
really yeah excited all the so that's
all the falcons tweeters
all right well you you know this fancy
set all of our
up-to-date picks connor's hair none of
it
is possible our sponsor rock and
mortgage
we're talking all show about perfect
fits so trust
us when we say that if you need home
loans that perfectly fit your life
rocket can need a bigger work from home
area rocket can
any sort of obstacle between you and
your perfect home
that's right you guessed it rocket can
you do have gray hair connor by the way
i don't know if we if we discuss that
enough there should just be like a
connor
hair cam we had a we did have a glimpse
of one earlier
it's very important it's always perfect
but it doesn't look stiff it's
very like superhero it's the longest
part of getting ready for the show more
so than the draft prospects
and speaking of those prospects we're
excited to talk a little madden now
we're bringing in
mmg and obviously there's a lot of
franchise changing players in this class
especially at the top of those guys on
offense
mmg thanks for joining us man what's
going on how we feeling it's good
how you doing good bro good bro so i
gotta start off the top
i mean we know all about trevor lawrence
and we know about justin fields and we
know all these guys but
who is your guy that is the when you
start a madden franchise or just a dude
that you want to see on madden
who's the dude there like this is the
guy i've actually been excited for i'm
tired of talking about the same old over
and over again
well according to my uh according to my
subscribers i'm just a casual
which is probably true honestly but
justin fields
absolutely justin fields i love justin
fields
i'm a little big to bias because i love
michigan state
uh i love ohio state i love all the big
ten schools but justin fields is
so incredible actually four years ago i
reacted to his high school highlight
clips
like forever ago which is super weird uh
seeing him go from high school to them
to osu
now in the league for the bears which is
super sad
because i'm gonna have to see him play
the lions two years straight
but uh he's a stud and you want this guy
a madden because he can scramble
everybody loves to scramble and madden i
don't know if it has the same
uh ability as it does the actual nfl
you've seen a lot of success from
quarterbacks who can't move
uh tom brady i'm looking at you but hey
justin fields is a stud
he can move he can pretty much do
anything as soon as i can i'm putting
him on alliance franchise i can promise
you that
yeah is there a speed demon that people
are just gonna be spamming with i mean
are we gonna i'm assuming it's gonna be
jalen waddle or someone like that but is
there someone that you're looking at and
you're just like
oh brother screens and verticals all day
that we're going to be stuck with
it's definitely jaylen waddle jayla
model's got to be it i mean the joke i
keep seeing on twitter is
every year someone drafts a tyreek hill
everybody wants to find their tyree kill
you know uh but this year the comparison
is jaylen waddle whether that holds up
uh is is yet to be seen but jaylen
waddles is stunned
he's got he's got the attributes if you
can somehow get a franchise with jayla
waddle justin fields on it
uh you'll be dominating that league for
the upcoming years that's for sure
yeah the quarterbacks and the skill guys
get all the love and understandably so
whether it's fantasy football whether
it's madden on non-on but give me
somebody on the defensive side
of the ball that actually has you
excited
oh for my lions i don't know we just got
our muzzurike
uh and i really like that guy i'm
definitely a casual because when we
drafted him i was like i'm gonna be
honest i don't know who this is
but after seeing that we didn't play
this and seeing
what's that he didn't play this year so
you're not
it's not your fault oh i'm not oh okay
so i'm not a casual
i love you i'm telling you you are not a
casual i'm here to put the stamp
down that mmg is not a casual it's not
his fault that
levi owns enrique opted out of this
season so
listen i actually really like the lions
draft right now i mean you get penne sew
you build in the trenches
as a fan are you are you feeling good
about it
yeah you know you take everything with a
grain of salt as a lions fan
and i think there's a lot of other
franchises who can feel the exact same
way
uh there's so much hype every single
time we sing around
the biggest hype about this season
though is we got a full reset
uh patricia's out gm's out dan campbell
has
energy that i love worse comes the worst
dan campbell will get me amped we'll go
owen
16 and i'm ready to take a kneecap so
hey i'm i'm really excited this could
finally be
the rebuild yeah i mean look at this
this is actually a really really good
start and as a
as a jets guy i could tell you i used to
call matt patricia the gase of the nfc
so i feel your pain i live with your
pain i understand it
and you know you look at all these
offseason editions a lot of these are
meant to help maybe the biggest one in
jared goff
are you on the goth bandwagon are you
skeptical where are we at right now with
jared goff
i'm such a hater bro i'm sorry are you
i'm not i'm
a jerry the thing is it's it can't be an
upgrade
from stafford and that's definitely
biased i'm perfectly fine saying that
but stafford is an incredible
quarterback
i think since he's come in the league
he's been a top tier top 10 talented
quarterback
there just hasn't been the team around
him i don't see jared goff
playing to matt stafford caliber he will
have a couple more pieces around him but
one thing you notice a lot in the nfl is
there's a tried and true formula and
that's offensive line
and pass rushers and you can go a long
way with that i don't think anybody
would say that blake bortles is an
incredibly talented quarterback
but they they were very close to beating
the patriots in that playoff run
with blake with blake bortles under the
helm and they had an incredible
offensive line they had incredible pass
rush
so if the lions are going for that
formula we're building this we got a top
10 offensive line right now
and uh we keep building the pass stretch
which we have we just drafted two d
tackles
uh and we keep going at it i honestly
wouldn't think it would matter right now
i don't think we're the super bowl
contending team but i like the way we're
building
so i don't care if it's jared goff matt
stafford or
trace mcsorley back there i think we'll
be able to do it if we build a good
enough squad
yeah so when you were sitting there
watching the top 10 unfold was there a
little part of you that's like man can
we just take justin fields or even mac
jones or were you just like now build a
line and keep this thing going for a boy
oh
every part of me said justin fields
every part of me said yes in fields
but as i have been informed going back
to being a casual
uh the best player on the board at seven
was finessu
without a doubt is the best player on
the board that is the best pick
unique offensive line and it's really
really difficult to
as everybody knows it's really difficult
to draft uh offensive line depth in the
later rounds so when you have
a stud caliber you know player right in
front of you you gotta take it
so all right so i'm gonna ask for two
madden rate two madden ratings then that
i need from you penne sewell
and justin fields oh boy see i think
they're going to do justin fields dirty
i think they are kennesu will start out
around anywhere from a 79 to 81
even though i think talent-wise he's
probably higher you'll just make some
people really really mad if you go any
higher than that
as an ea ratings adjuster i think the
highest the highest anyone's going to
get is trevor lawrence he might start
out right around 84.
and justin fields is going to be like a
76 they're gonna make him a scrambler
prototype qb
and uh he's probably got the highest
ceiling he could definitely be
he could do some lamar jackson type
stuff and get up to a 99 real quick
that's what i want to see anyway mmg
thanks so much for joining us man
appreciate it of course
no worries thanks for having me yep
i love it i'm like should i learn how to
play madden
it's been a couple of years for me not
gonna lie but there was a time
there was a time i mean well back in the
day it was
michael vick and the falcons duh that's
a casual take but i don't care that's
shout out the georgia dome that's the
dude so but now
my bad days are behind me taylor i can't
keep up with these guys i'm embarrassed
but it's crazy people are so incredibly
into it
oh yeah franchise building gaming
streaming yeah it's huge oh i'm a gamer
i'm just not a madden guy okay what's
your game that's the difference of
course call of duty oh
okay reluctantly got taylor i got like
this when the draft was coming up i had
to do a call of duty ban
like where i didn't i had to like not
play for like 45 days because it's like
it's
i got draft crunch time yeah so you're
like one of those i get on at like 6 p.m
and i'm not off to like 1am well i'm not
that lucky anymore but
i'm not that lucky he's like all right i
don't tell anyone how much i am addicted
to call of duty but
okay very fair recent picks
yeah see where we at i've actually this
is the first time i've missed the board
so let's go down here you know it's
crazy
once again of course the ravens just do
what they do and take the guys that i
like that fell too far sean wade to the
ravens is one that
he can come in and be a slot corner for
them and they develop players taylor
that's the most important thing they
know how to develop players
and i forget who it was that went off
the board yesterday to them but
you know a little not low but knew the
player needed time and it keep even said
it that's a place where
you trust what they do the program and
how they
get guys to where they need to be so
there goes jamar johnson to the broncos
as well someone we've been waiting on
man the broncos just know safeties i
mean they really really do when you look
at it they just
understand safety play and how to get
ball hawking stars they sit in it too
high
and they don't move their safeties it's
gonna you're gonna play on the left
you're gonna play on the right and
you're gonna sit in two high
that's good for jamar johnson he's
someone that could even be a third
safety you want to roll him out there
run with tight ends run with the slot
he's got the range over the top and
let's look at the big board right now
you're talking about the best players
available here
i'm going to just bang the table for
trey smith and devon and deontay brown
i mean it's a lot of the same on the
left side there right but let's talk
about the newcomers the new face
sardarius washington
i'm not surprised he's not taking yet
he's not going to be everyone's flavor
undersized safety with not a lot of
speed
he's all instincts feisty in coverage
he'll find a way to make it in the
league seth williams from
from auburn wide receiver strange player
one of those ones where the highlights
tremendous there's times where it just
doesn't look like he's in the game and i
think that's because of the quarterback
play though that was a huge problem so
seth williams big body wide receiver
big target and it always reminds me i
told this story a little bit yesterday
but i remember when darius slayton came
out
everybody was like oh you know now he's
the star for the giants he's doing this
what happened to auburn it's like well
the quarterback play was not there for
slayton to succeed down the field
now he's in an nfl system where he can
succeed vertically so
seth williams is a good good target and
then we got more picks coming in here
new pick carolina panthers draft
washington corner keith taylor
yeah i mean we're getting to the point
of the draft right now where you're
getting guys that are either sneaking in
the top 250 or aren't there but keith
taylor
kind of an interesting process in this
all he's a guy that
he did make the top 250 i had him at 233
long press corner from washington with
the no ball production there's just
he doesn't play the football but he can
run down the field he can press he could
he could tackle he was really reliable
for the huskies and that's a program
that takes a lot of
pride in that secondary they get corners
drafted off the board every single year
we did elijah moore yesterday when he
came off the board
the slot guy kind of a hybrid safety
taylor's
not like that at all he's on the outside
boundary corner hey can you press hey
can you bail
can you just keep in the hip pocket of
your target we don't need the
interceptions from you we don't need the
ball skills all the time so
you're trying to deepen the roster
you're trying to get ready hey if we
have an injury or two at outside corner
can this guy come in and play
he's an interesting one just one of
those really really tall
lanky kind of players that was very
successful at that program
but once again will the ball skills ever
click i don't think so
all right absolutely all right you keep
your eyes on the boards
do all the connor things that you do
during the nfl draft
as we welcome in our next guest we have
olivia
reiner here to talk all things packers
and there are so many things to talk
about now
olivia i'm sure that work has been so
boring these past couple days right you
know it's not like a
hall of fame league mvp quarterback you
know allegedly running out of green bay
right
yeah been an awfully boring 48 hours for
the packers as reports have surfaced
that aaron rodgers is disgruntled with
the packers and has told some within the
organization that he is not interested
in returning to the team in 2021.
that's quite a bit of an issue the
packers certainly don't want to see
aaron rodgers go they've got
quarterback jordan love who they drafted
in the first round last year
they moved up to draft jordan love in
the first round of the draft last year
he's not exactly ready he was widely
considered to be a project when he was
first
drafted and they were hoping to see him
develop behind aaron rodgers over the
next few years
right now that's a big question with
rogers apparently wanting out
love might not be ready and the packers
might be in a little bit of a tricky
situation with their franchise
quarterback
yeah and i do want to talk about jordan
love a bit because you know that is a
name that is thrown around so much when
we're talking about aaron rodgers but we
don't know much else about him
except for the fact that he might be why
you know aaron rodgers is so upset
at the moment reports out now of course
that aaron would like the gm to be
fired uh what insight do you have on
that
not much besides that clearly as the
reports have been
coming out it sounds like his
disgruntlement concerns jordan love and
the way that that pick was handled the
lack of communication that surrounded
the pick and the packers
moving up to draft a quarterback yes to
draft a quarterback so there's some
concern there that he wasn't notified
and so that's where they are right now
there's some frustration it seems with
the front office
and so what what do they do now does he
want heads to roll does he want to see
general manager brian goodkins out does
aaron rodgers have the
right to have that kind of power over
this organization it's
really fascinating and the answer is i
don't know
i'm really intrigued to see how this is
going to play out just as much as
everybody else
for sure well when you look at you know
what the packers brass is doing in the
draft it seems like
they are trying to do what they can to
appease aaron rodgers
so my question is do you think they're
doing enough and
is doing enough even possible at this
point olivia
at this point no i don't think there's
much they can do they can
trade up into the first round and draft
nine
wide receivers i don't think it really
makes a difference
and i would also push back on the idea
that the packers
need to draft to appease aaron rodgers
the packers need to do what's best for
the green bay packers and that's what
they've been doing
they're drafting a cornerback in the
first round and eric stokes
because the packers secondary wasn't all
that good especially in the nfc
championship game last year
when the packers defense is good that
means that the packers offense can get
on the field which means
aaron rodgers gets on the field that's a
good thing for the packers
so the packers need to continue to
develop their defense
they also drafted offensive lineman a
center
in josh myers out of ohio state so
you're getting some protection
presumably up front for aaron rodgers
with corey linsley departing in free
agency for the los
angeles chargers and then oh yeah they
did draft a wide receiver in the third
round amari rogers out of clemson
who yeah could presumably catch passes
from aaron rodgers to next season
or not i don't know um but at this point
i don't think the packers are drafting
for
aaron rodgers they're drafting for
jordan love i
i think they need to work out the aaron
rodgers deal they've been trying
they've flown out to the west coast
several times individually matt lefleur
president ceo mark murphy and general
manager brian goodkins to ball flown out
west at separate times throughout this
offseason
to try and meet with him and talk to him
and clearly things haven't gone anywhere
you know i want to go back to jordan
love who you just mentioned
obviously everybody wanted him to be
able to learn and develop
under anne rogers as you said if that's
not the case it seems as though you're
saying he is not necessarily ready right
now how far away
is he from being ready
that's a great question we don't really
know we haven't seen him
play very much he hasn't had the
opportunity to play
no preseason last season so he didn't
get those very important snaps
not to mention he wasn't even the backup
quarterback to aaron rodgers last year
he was the
third string quarterback to aaron
rodgers tim boyle who's now with the
detroit alliance who
was a restricted free agent this past
this offseason and the packers decided
not to
offer him a tender he walks becomes an
unrestricted free agent and signed with
signs with the lions
he was the backup so he's getting more
reps in practice than jordan love is so
jordan love got a little more work in in
training camp
and he was working behind the scenes in
practice
however besides that we don't really
know he hasn't had that many reps he
hasn't had the opportunities
that even a backup quarterback would
have so how could he possibly be
be ready when he was drafted last year
he was considered to be more of a
project that would need to take some
time
to wait behind aaron rodgers and what a
great situation
in theory it ended up being however
that's not the way that this is working
out so
it's a great question if rogers were to
depart via trade
it would behoove the packers to acquire
a veteran quarterback
so that jordan love can continue to wait
and develop and they don't have to put
all of their eggs in one basket before
he is ready
yeah definitely just a lot of questions
a lot of things that uh
packers and packers fans are unsure of
but some things we are sure of packers
got some solid picks
uh so let's talk about some of those
guys um i
am a big fan of the eric stokes pick we
just had deandre swift on here talking
about his former teammate i was saying
obviously
he had four interceptions last season
only allowed three touchdowns
in coverage um in his career in athens
how will he help
green bay i think he has an opportunity
to
make a massive impact on this packers
secondary right now
the packers cornerbacks the situation
there jair alexander
is a sure thing starter and unbelievable
player
but next to him the pairing on the
outside with kevin king
is a bit of a question the packers
brought back kevin king who was an
unrestricted free agent this offseason
on a one-year five million dollar deal
which would indicate that there's some
level of confidence in kevin king that
he can play
had a bit of a rough nfc championship
game against the tampa bay buccaneers in
which the peckers of course
lost and king is back much to
the disgruntlement of some packers fans
however i think that he has a shot at
being the starter that being stead said
stokes can give king a run for his money
stokes might even have an opportunity to
play in the slot when the packers are in
nickel so there might be some
rep potential reps for him there
additionally i think stokes can
possibly contribute on special teams
this packers special teams units over
the past couple of seasons have been
absolutely
abysmal ranking in the bottom of the
league for the past two seasons and
while some may say why on earth would
they draft a player
in this position just to have them
contribute on special teams i think
he'll be more than that however
he's a fast guy four to five at his pro
day at least
that's what he said i'm not so sure
about these pro day numbers in
this particular offseason however even
if he's in the vicinity of four
to five to be there it means he's about
4-3 which is
absolutely lightning fast still i think
he can be a great gunner on special
teams
yes i'm sure packers fans will take that
um also grabbed a center uh josh myers
out of ohio state seems
very versatile looks like he can play
any of the three interior line spots
what will you all be getting from him
what a surprise the packers are
interested in ohio state centers once
again
as i already mentioned corey linsley
departed in free agency for the los
angeles chargers he was an ohio native
from ohio state so clearly the packers
have a thing for ohio state
centers that's if anyone ever wants to
go play for the packers just you know go
go to ohio state earn that scholarship
and start its center but clearly they
really like him
he's six foot five 310 pounds that is a
massive massive center of a tackle in a
center's body or maybe vice versa i
suppose
i think he'll be able to contribute
right away to this offensive line with
linsley departing in free agency to
at the very least compete for that
center
starter role uh with the on the packers
offensive line there's a lot of influx
on the offensive line
in this offseason with left tackle david
bachtiari dealing with an
acl injury so he will likely he's not
going to be ready
for week one it's a question of will he
be back in week three
will he be back in week eight possibly
later we don't know
so there's gonna be some shuffling
however one of the
key figures that the packers may want to
shuffle
is elton jenkins who's been able to play
tackle he's been able to play guard
however i think his role is
at the moment i i would think he's going
to play guard this upcoming season
if the packers have confidence in myers
to start at center we'll see
right now we we touched on him a bit but
the packers grabbed a wide receiver in
fact traded
up to grab him uh mari rogers out of
clemson
looks like he can be a special player
what are your thoughts on amari
absolutely they did draft up and they
pretty much pointed up a
pretty penny for rogers too not only did
they trade
their own third round pick but they also
took their
one of their fourth round picks as well
and packaged that with the tennessee
titans to trade up
and get rogers however general manager
brian goodkin said
listen we we wanted the player and
that's ultimately what they got
and this is a player that is going to
fill a very important role for the
packers
in this offense and matt lefleur's
offense he loves to have
a jet motion player a slot receiver it's
not necessarily something that the
packers have had for a little while
the packers had wide receiver randall
cobb in their
arsenal and when he departed for the
houston texans it left a pretty gaping
hole in this packers offense
and they tried to plug it up with
various players over
over the years most recently running
back slash wide receiver tyler irvin was
playing that
jet motion roll and it just wasn't great
he wasn't as durable
rogers is a little bit more durable he's
short he's five foot nine however
212 pounds he is capable of
weathering the green bay freezing cold
all that good stuff
i think he'll be a pretty solid pick for
the packers
all right well thank you and i hope that
you get
some rest i'm sure it has been a
whirlwind covering the packers these
past couple days
but thank you so much for giving us your
insight and joining us here on the show
much appreciated
anytime i'm looking forward to a nap
maybe
at some point who knows thanks olivia
[Music]
all right well look at this the packers
derby crew including qb of the weekend
aaron rodgers he has pulled up he is
there
wow i mean imagine having to make like a
public appearance
when the entire nfl world is talking
about trailer he didn't have to
exactly which is important yes
very important yeah very very smart
distinction do we think we'll hear
anything from aaron today i think we
will he he'll give that little like kind
of
quiet smirk and chill energy and just
you know
i don't i don't think we'll get anything
too crazy but i wouldn't be surprised if
he says
yeah i think if anything's very subtle
someone might ask him a question he
might give a one or two word a little
answer and leave it at that
and you'll all be wondering for another
week
all right so we got some picks on the
board here garrett wallow a special team
star an undersized linebacker in houston
and then you look at
you know daylen hayes goes to baltimore
that's a not a surprise fit
strong edge setter can come in and kind
of handle some of the dirty work there
against the run
he's had some shoulder injuries
throughout his career so you just hope
dalen can get on the field because i
know he was
very very well liked at notre dame and
somebody that's really really easy to
root for and
now we get to the you know the best
available not much has changed here
i'll get i'll get up talk about carrie
vincent jr there the slot corner
out of lsu speed for days he can run
with anybody i think you could use him
at safety a little bit as that third
safety role
could be a gunner on special teams with
the kind of speed he has but he's a slot
corner and
there's been a lot of slot guys taken
care of vincent jr is better than a lot
of them so i look at this
i'll say it again a lot of these guys
should not be on the board happens every
single year and then
you know they come in and ball out and
find themselves on a 53-man roster
and i mean on that subject trey smith
dionte brown
why are they still there well trade has
to be medical right
i could give a good example i remember a
couple years ago
you know when you look at someone like
maurice hurst i believe he had a heart
condition
and i asked teams and you know i know
one team that really wanted him and they
said my doctor will not allow it it's
not up to the coaches it's not for the
scouts it's up to the doctor for the
team doctor so
i'm not saying that's definitively
what's happening but i'm giving an
example in the past of a reason why a
talented player like that
might not be medically cleared it could
be a team-by-team basis teams have their
own thresholds and rules and some are
more harsh than
others so i think for trey it's probably
a medical related issue because he's a
great football player
and i'm you know once again really
rooting for him because i
think that he bounced back really nicely
at tennessee after that
after that hurdle and then you look at
deontay brown you know he's a little
scheme specific
he's going to be in a power blocking
scheme you go back to baltimore you're
looking for dry blockers you go back to
the raiders you're looking for dry
blockers they took his teammate alex
leatherwood
guys that can really just move you
forward not guys that need to get out of
their stance and get wide and create
angles and
deante's got good feet for a heavy guy
but still teams will look at that and be
like we just don't think he can get to
the spots that we need him to
he has no business being on the board
let me make that clear right now
somebody will get a steal yeah when you
look at these guys
that are still on the board that
probably thought they were going to go
much earlier when they end up on a team
do you think there is some truth to how
that really fuels them once they're
there
yeah it does it gives them a little chip
on their shoulder and i'll say another
thing people don't think about is that
if they don't get drafted at all they
get to choose where they go
and you know i was having a conversation
with an agent recently where it was like
they're comfortable with certain players
they represent hitting the free agent
period rather than being drafted in the
sixth or seventh round
because you can feel out the rosters and
say i know he can go be
the fifth wide receiver there i know he
could be the third tight end there he
could be the fourth safety there
rather than getting drafted into a spot
being pigeon-holed into a role that
doesn't make a lot of sense for the guy
and then he gets cut that doesn't do
anybody any good so
you know you want to hear your name
called on draft day and you want to
celebrate with your family and celebrate
all the hard work you've done your whole
life
but if you're looking at the long-term
picture and if you're frustrated that
you're not taking in the sixth or
seventh round
sometimes being an undrafted free agent
can really help you
is there any team that sticks out in
your mind that has a need they really
needed to address this draft they maybe
got like one piece but you like to see
them get
one or two more yeah i think i go back
to the giants who have done such a nice
job this year
and i still personally have some
questions and i'm pulling up their draft
board now i want to make sure we didn't
miss anyone they have two picks left
they're picking twice in the sixth round
okay they got two edge rushers had to do
it and they got our guy oh jalari gonna
kill it
and then they got aaron robinson a
feisty man-to-man corner
so when you look at the giants there
they still need a guard
and those two guys are sitting on the
board and they fit the scheme
so i think that makes a lot of sense you
know you look here the draft additions
of a team like the lions
they're somebody that just knocked it
out of the park but they're a team that
had so much work to do on their roster
that they have to keep going but they're
on the right direction they can afford
to take best players available they're
building in the trenches
i think that's something that's really
really exciting about the lions they
know they need to protect jared goff
they know they had a lot of picks and a
staff that really needed to hit it out
of the park you can't
miss a lot you need a franchise tackle
in pen a sewell now you have bookends on
the outside you need interior players
that can rush the passer and stop the
run
you got that you got a value linebacker
they just did they got a value
cornerback that's a starter
if you come out of a giraffe tailor with
three starters in the nfl it's seen as a
gigantic win
i think the lion's got four starters in
this draft well one thing that
is interesting to me about the lions you
know
jared is facing a bit of a drop-off in
terms of wide receiver talent just in
general a bit less than i would say that
he's used to obviously they no longer
have kenny goloday they no longer have
you know marvin jones it's hard for me
to believe this is going to be
a sean mcvay year for jared goff
what will his what will his weapons do
for him
in detroit it's a great question they're
going to have to run the heck out of the
football right right
you know which we talk what you talked
about exactly and deandre swift uh
he was uh my top running back last year
and i thought that he was somebody that
was a little
underdrafted in the draft process and
somebody that you can
run the rock with a lot and it's an
exciting way big plays those 15 to 20
yard pickups so
now he's got the guys to run behind you
had penne sold they're gonna run the
heck out of the football and they're
going to skip off the defense is going
to get
off the field because they got levi
allen's enrique you could shoot gap
celine mcneil the
the unmovable object could stop the run
it fought to melefano i thought was a
really nice cover three corner with
length and speed
now you go back to your question about
goff this guy has to step up a monroe st
brown now not a lot of players drafted
outside the top 100
you look at them and go man we need you
to be something they need him to be
something and he was a quarterback's
best friend at usc a guy that can go up
win contested catch situations
make a play on the football those are
the kind of guys jared goff thrives with
all right let's take a look at some of
your best picks
day three yes absolutely i think it
starts for me here with tylen wallace
going to the ravens i think when you
you get a player like that at this point
of the draft that consistently won
over the top at that level rashad
bateman's going to be the middle of the
field receiver they took him in round
one
wallace you get that late he's your
vertical stretch guy for lamar jackson
lamar's got a lot of new weapons and you
love that can he gain well to the eagles
like i said reminds me a little bit of
lashawn mccoy pass catching running back
with really really shifty player in the
open field
the rich get richer jalen darden goes to
the bucks tom brady's got a fifth wide
receiver that on most teams would be the
third or fourth wide receiver
drew dalman we didn't talk about him
today one of my favorite centers in the
draft for your falcons taylor
plug and play center great in his own
scheme great hands little undersized
very very strong very reliable and pass
protection and cam
sample the edge defender at a two lane
for the bengals good at leverage good at
stopping the run
can drive tackles back into the pocket a
really strong player plays with an edge
i like his attitude
these are the value picks these are some
big time winning picks on day three this
is how you get to the playoffs
yeah i always love it because i can tell
who your favorite guys are just you're
like
your eyes light up it up a little more
yeah absolutely
okay you know we got to do our to the
moon takes tell me something you think
is going to happen next year with our
draftees that maybe
isn't the conventional opinion i think
azizo jalari is in for an eight to ten
sack season
that's my to the moon take right it's
not my i know this is gonna happen this
is my
you know you're investing in dodge coin
for two cents and then you're looking up
and you're like wait i made a quick
grand like
something like that where i think
ojalari is someone that should have been
a first round player whatever happened
with him medically
is what happened he that's out of his
hands and the giants are saying we
believe in you
i think if you get ogilari on the field
for 75 of the snaps
let him attack let him get up field he
can be an eight sack player as a rookie
he has that kind of talent
playing next to leonard williams too so
ojolari is going to see some one-on-ones
there i really think that's the edge
rusher the giants needed
okay i'm gonna give one please say it's
crazy
this is also fingers crossed julio stays
in the falcons i am not with this hole
let's get rid of julio absolutely not
he's the best
but i think that kyle pitts will have
more touchdowns in either julio or
calvin
one of them i like that maybe both of
things get crazy
maybe both who knows why can't kyle
pitts and i know the fantasy footballers
they nailed this
rookie tight ends do not produce kyle
pitts is not your average
joe rookie tight end when they're in the
red zone i don't care if he's covered by
two guys throw kyle pits the ball
i'm with you taylor i'm with that that's
my pick i do have one more question for
you if you had to pick
one winner of this year's draft what
team is that wow you know you heard me
love the lions i like the niners i like
the ravens and i always like the ravens
draft
i'm a big fan of rashad bateman i'm a
big fan of away at the pass rush spot
ben cleveland's a starting guard to me
you know tylen wallace i already gushed
about him to win over the top i think
sean wade can bounce back as a slot
corner so
i thought the ravens did a really nice
job and and you talk about those san
francisco 49ers i'm gonna cheat here and
give you another one
that's the team for me you got you trade
it up for trey lance he could be a
superstar and i think he will be with
kyle shanahan
aaron banks compared him to lake and
tomlinson already a stalwart on their
offensive line banks is the next man
up trey sermon we really like him as a
rotational running back
ambry thomas physical feisty man corner
jaylen moore plays with an edge on the
offensive line he could be a future
starter at guard
maybe a swing tackle the 49ers
they've got some questionable drafts
over the years they're well coached
they develop talent they have some weird
picks this year i never really felt like
that with them i felt like all their
picks were good value
made a lot of sense for their scheme i
want trey lance to be a superstar in san
francisco go light it up there yeah i
have a bit of a weird pick for my winner
i'm going to go with the bears not
because of all their picture because
they were under such heavy pr heavy
pressure i feel like they got done what
needed to be done
i'm big justin fields fan i'm absolutely
with that they got
him some o-line protection i'm gonna go
with the bears they had some lofty
expectations i think they did what they
needed to do
and i love that take because you look at
the bears they needed two things they
needed a franchise quarterback that can
give them energy and turn them around
justin fields could do that then you
need the second thing you got to protect
them
they got tevin jenkins in the second
round a first round player so
yeah and then you got larry borum so
another guy that's going to plug in at
guard at the next level he might not
start but he could fight to start
this is the future of the bears
franchise justin fields and i think he
could be a star
i really like him and even if he doesn't
blossom into a star he should be an
above average quarterback because he is
so
accurate with the football bears haven't
had a quarterback like him in a
long long time and you know i'm a little
happy for justin fields
he's a guy that deserves to be wanted by
an nfl team not overlooked and they said
we'll trade two first-round picks and
come get you go win the starting job
go be a superstar in the city of chicago
yeah this is absolutely a defining
draft for the chicago bears but speaking
of quarterbacks i think we have
one more aaron rodgers tweet
all right aaron rodgers at the kentucky
derby he declined to talk to nbc mike
trico says rogers told him he was
disappointed
that news has come out of this rift with
the packers trico says rogers expressed
how much
he loves green bay to be continued
oh there's always going to be something
we will keep our eyes on that
connor this was a joy i learned so much
from eunice in these last couple hours
thank you to the fans for watching for
leaving comments thank you so much to
rocket mortgage
thank you connor for knowing way too
much about everything and
yes this was so much fun thank you guys
so much have an amazing day and best of
luck
to all of your teams next season bye
guys
[Music]
[Music]
you